over the course of a film and television
career that's spanned over 30 years
Johnny Depp has played more than a few
strange characters some have been part
of his bizarre collaborative history
with director Tim Burton which has seen
him become everyone from Willie Wonka to
Sweeney Todd but he's also always
marched to the beat of A Different
Drummer by himself though he's had a
tortured relationship with Fame Johnny
Depp is still a master of his craft and
an extremely interesting guy to boot
Even after spending all these years in
the Limelight there's still plenty
that's been left out of the headlines
about the enigmatic actor and musician
this is the Untold Truth of Johnny Depp
auspicious start there's a long-standing
Hollywood rumor that Johnny Depp first
got his start after his first wife
introduced him to her ex-boyfriend who
just so happened to be Nicholas Cage and
Depp has somewhat corroborated the story
in his own words and somebody said well
why don't you go meet an agent meet my
agent you know was Nick Cage and he said
go go meet my agent and she sent me to
audition for something and I got it cage
reportedly saw something in Depp and
opened some crucial early career doors
for him soon after he was cast in his
first film role in a Nightmare on Elm
Street and with that he was officially
an actor making movie Magic thanks to
projects like platoon crybaby 21 Jump
Street and Edward Scissor Hands Johnny
Depp started to boast some clout in
Tinseltown in the early '90s the film he
decided to cash his chips in on was
What's Eating Gilbert Grape so The Story
Goes then girlfriend wiona Ryder read
Peter hedge's novel of the same name and
got deppt to read it too he felt it was
a modern-day catcher in the Ry and
identified strongly with Gilbert a young
man trapped in a small town and saddled
with family responsibilities it was a
residue you know that was sort of left
over from my childhood that I connected
to and you know with that character and
with those people Depp then told
director Lassa hollstrom about the book
and the two agreed to work on the film
before there was even a script in place
hrom Enlisted the author Hedges to work
on the script and the rest was movie
history sticking to music when Johnny
Depp first came to California he
actually didn't intend to be an actor he
was actually in a band called the kids
who'd been pretty successful around the
greater Southeast de actually dropped
out of high school because of the band
and they opened for National acts like
the Talking Heads The Pretenders and the
Ramones after the band split up he
turned to acting but Depp never forgot
his love for music and was in the Glam
band Rock City Angels before making his
screen breakthrough Deb later started
the band P with Butthole Surfers
frontman Gibby Haynes although they
broke up fairly quickly he remained
musically active most recently he's been
in a band called The Hollywood vampires
alongside Alice Cooper Aeros Smith
guitarist Joe Perry and Guns and Roses
vets Duff McKagan and Matt sorum the
members say they've all had brushes with
de and Depp in particular seems to feel
lucky to be part of the
collaboration kid-friendly by portraying
Captain Jack Sparrow in the Pirates of
the Caribbean series Johnny Depp got to
bring a lot of joy to Children both in
and outside of the theaters he spent a
great deal of his free time suiting up
in the character cost him to visit
Children's Hospitals and SCH schools and
the reason for his particular fondness
for children has a little something to
do with his own experiences as a father
they're giving me the gift I was the
parent um when my daughter was ill and
I've known darkness in my life but uh
that was the darkest period ever you
know of course Jack Sparrow isn't the
only character he has embodied to bring
joy to his youngest fans in 2016 he
acted in the black gandola a micro
budgeted movie about a young man who in
the wake of a zombie apocalypse risks
everything to save the life of his
companion the short movie came together
thanks to the make a film Foundation a
charity which helps film making dreams
come true for kids and teens with
serious medical problems the film was
written by and starred Anthony kti a
16-year-old who is stricken with stage
four adrenal cortical cancer and Depp
happily joined in as one of the film
supporting a-listers cinematic chameleon
Johnny Depp has tried on so many
different screen personas that it's
entirely possible that even he doesn't
know what he looks or sounds like
anymore even in interviews he tends to
talk with affectations that sound like
they're somewhere between Great Britain
Boston and Wonderland and he also seems
to enjoy disappearing into his roles
well the last thing I want to look like
is myself you know um I I've always felt
that it was important
to escape so if you ever wondered why he
tends to choose roles that make him
virtually unrecognizable it's because he
seems to prefer onscreen anonymity even
still he refuses to watch his own movies
anyway I've seen only a couple that I've
had to see like for just just to check
for you know the cut or whatever to make
sure that the cut was cool getting
political in addition to making movies
and music Depp has also been known to
use his platform to raise awareness for
political causes alongside several other
socially conscious artists Depp
participated in the voice projects
imprisoned for art campaign in late 2016
appearing in a mug shot to shed light on
a Ukrainian filmmaker serving a 20-year
jail sentence in Siberia Depp is also no
fan of Donald Trump and appeared in a
Funny or Die Lost movie called The Art
of the deal based on the Trump book by
the same name the movie was posted the
morning Trump won the New Hampshire
primary but deps continued to whip out
his spot-on Impressions on command well
I got a feel for him because he's
Sensational absolutely fabulous I told
them to build me f wall I want a
sensational wall if Alex Baldwin ever
decides to stop impersonating the
president on Saturday Night Live it
looks like Johnny Depp could fit right
into it personal problems as much as he
might like to sink into his screen roles
in recent years Johnny Depp's personal
life has become a very publicized roller
coaster he and former wife Amber herd
caused something of an international
incident in 2015 when they traveled to
Australia to film the latest Pirates
installment and brought along their two
Yorkshire Terriers upon arrival the
couple failed to properly declare the
animals with Customs
officials Mr Depp has to either take his
dogs back to California or we're going
to have to euthanize them they were
forced to return turn the smuggled
animals to the United States and herd
pleaded guilty to knowingly producing a
false or misleading document for failing
to disclose the dogs the two ended up
delivering an awkward apology video
which he was later able to laugh about I
would really like to
apologize for not smuggling my dogs but
that was just the start of their
problems their marriage soon after ended
in disaster as the actress claims that
he'd been abusive to her during their
relationship she also alleged that Depp
was addicted to alcohol and other
substances though their divorce was
finalized relatively quickly Depp dayss
of making headlines for all the wrong
reasons were far from over Financial wos
with over $50 million worth of property
in one of Hollywood's most interesting
resumés to his name it was a bit
shocking to learn that Johnny Depp has
major money problems shortly after his
split from her Depp's legal Wes raged on
after his attorney and accountant
informed him that he was financially
underwater the two reportedly had to
make Depp understand that his income was
being outpaced by his spending on
luxuries like art jewelry wine property
and the $3.6 million per year he paid
his personal staff Depp finally agreed
to sell his yacht but it was the start
of a tense communication between the
three that would end with Depp firing
both of his advisers Depp went on to
allege that his former managers caused
him to rack up more than $40 million in
debt and to dispose of valuable assets
and that they talked him into highin
loans that they didn't make payments on
they responded by claiming that Depp was
irresponsible prompting legal actions on
both sides in January 2017 Depp filed
suit against the management group for
mismanagement of his wealth and for
defrauding him out of money during the
course of their duties between 1999 and
2016 Depp claimed that the company
siphoned some $28 million and that they
didn't pay his taxes on time TMG counter
sued if all of that wasn't bad enough
he's also been sued by his former
bodyguards for unpaid wages and unsafe
work conditions thin but okay Johnny
Depp appeared in two major films in 2017
murderer on the Orient Express and
Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Men tell
no tales and lined up a few more for
2018 including the Fantastic Beast
sequel the crimes of grindlewald Depp
looked mostly like his youthful self in
those films which is why fans were
shocked when an odd picture of the actor
circulated around the internet in Spring
2018 where he's posing with a fan in
Russia looking ghostly pale and
skeletally thin while Depp often
drastically Alters his appearance for
films the sudden physical transformation
still proved alarming leaving fans
wondering why Depp was looking so skinny
blaming everything from drug addiction
to preparing for a movie role as it
happens it's probably for a film Depp is
set to star in a dramedy called Richard
says goodbye as a professor dying of a
terminal illness Depp obviously still
has no trouble scoring promising
projects even now working lunch I'm on a
roll the Man known as Jackie Chan is one
of the biggest and most badass movie
stars ever and the first to bridge the
gap between Hong Kong action Cinema and
big big budget American movies Chan
might be past 60 but he's still putting
his life on the line to Thrill
audiences read the womb though it may
seem like the big screen Legend has been
around forever Jackie Chan was born Chan
Kong sang in April 1954 there was
nothing weird about that until you
realized he was supposed to be born in
January of that year yep he hung out in
his mother's womb for a full 12 months
before a British doctor had to
surgically remove him at the time of his
forced birth he weighed 12 his mother
nicknamed him powpow or Cannonball my
wife had such a difficult time
delivering him afterward she was totally
exhausted the nurse brought the baby in
saying oh he's so cute just like a
cannonball nevertheless that kind of
medical procedure isn't cheap and Chan's
parents couldn't afford it thus they
tried to sell their baby to the doctor
who delivered him the doctor said no
obviously according to Chan's Memoir his
parents gave gathered the money from
their friends and needed a decade to pay
them all back learning from Legends when
Jackie Chan was 7 years old he was
enrolled and boarded at the China drama
Academy where he was taught acting and
singing in preparation for a career in
the pay King Opera it was there Chan
lived and trained for the next 10 years
eventually forming an acrobatic troop
with some classmates called the seven
little fortunes upon leaving school Chan
used the group to gain his first roles
in home Kong movies he and the seven
little fortunes were extras and stunt
men in Enter the Dragon and Fists of
Fury two of the most famous and popular
movies ever made by Bruce Lee Chan even
got to spar on camera with the screen
Legend sat my eyes all black because he
just one stick right on my
head picky with voice Parts while a star
in Asia since the 1970s Jackie Chan
wasn't a main dream star in the US until
the release of Rumble in the Bronx in
1996 before that he helped bring
American movies to Asia for example he
provided the Mandarin language voice
acting of the Beast for the Chinese dub
of Beauty and the Beast Chan has since
done Voice work in the English language
releases of other major animated movies
one notable example being his portrayal
of Master monkey in the Kung Fu Panda
movies however you might be surprised to
hear of the one place he didn't land his
voice the cartoon series Jackie Chan
Adventures although he appeared in
liveaction bumpers for the show the
cartoon version of Jackie Chan is voiced
by James C but I don't know anything
about children who also incidentally
took over his master monkey in the TV
series spin-off of Kung Fu Panda to make
things even more confusing the character
of Jade Chan Jackie's fictional niece on
the series was voiced by Stacy Chan
Jackie Chan's real life niece no
stranger to Danger after starring in
dozens of martial arts and action movies
in which he's done his own stunts Jackie
Jan has sustained a number of injuries
so much so that in 2013 his movie
Chinese zodiac was promoted in Japan
with a poster that consisted of an image
of Chan's body with arrows pointing to
all of his injured body parts among the
injuries Chan has suffered in the
pursuit of entertainment on Drunken
Master he damaged a bone behind his
eyebrow and it nearly blinded him on
City Hunter he dislocated his right
shoulder on the armor of God Chan fell
out of a tree and suffered a skull
fracture a bone cave in behind the ear
and bleeding into his brain during
surgery bone chips were removed from his
head two finger two fingers yeah take
these two fingers I'm B I'm bowling with
Jackie Chan oh my God yes yes yes yes he
broke his breast bone on Armor of God 2
during the filming of The Accidental Spy
he broke his tailbone and was
temporarily paralyzed oh and he's broken
his no know four separate times once
while making the young Master once on
Project a once on Miracles and once on
Mr Nice Guy ouch we'll never complain
about a stubbed toe again broken broken
this gone just a chick broken broken
broken uh crack crack crack crack crack
the 1,000th times a charm directors may
require a lot to get the scene the way
they want it in one example of this
borderline abusive practice Stanley
kubri infamously required Shelley Duval
to film one scene in The Shining 127
Times by that logic the most sadistic
director that Jackie Chan has ever
worked with is himself while directing
and starring in the 1982 movie dragon
lord a sequence in which characters play
Giani a Chinese sport similar to hacki
saak but with a weighted badminton style
shuttlecock just didn't look right to
director Chan it's been reported that
the scene took 2,900 t takes but it
probably didn't take that many the book
Kung Fu Masters places the number over
190 and other estimates come in at over
1,000 either way chanon was dedicated to
the
shot tough love Jackie Chan's a movie
star which means he's Rich he's a master
Fortune of over $350 million in addition
to earning salary and box office
percentages from his films he's owned a
chain of movie theaters and a segue
dealership and when he dies a lot of it
is going to charity but his son JC Chan
who was convicted on drug charges in
2015 stands to inherit exactly none of
that in 2011 Chan publicly mentioned
that he won't leave his fortune behind
to his son remarking if he is capable he
can make his own money if he is not then
he will be just wasting my money it
seems like there's a little more to the
story than that especially considering
the fact that their relationship isn't
without its past bumps in the road
Jackie once even admitted that he had
beaten JC when he was a child admitting
that he was not a moral father but it
looks like threats of violence are off
the table these days wearing the white
shoes running around because he don't
wash his own shoes you give him a shot
no I can you saw me polarizing politics
while Jackie Chan boasts fans from every
corner of the globe he's still very
loyal to his home nation of China's
political system of Communism in fact
he's way more political outspoken than
most of his fans probably realize he's
even opened up about his opinions on the
American way of life on more than one
occasion in 2013 he said what I can see
is China continuously making progress in
learning if you talk about corruption
the entire world the United States has
no corruption it's the most corrupt in
the world but his opinions don't end
with the US in 2009 he talked about the
dangers of too much freedom in China
controlled Taiwan saying I don't know
whether it's better to have freedom or
to have no Freedom with too much Freedom
it gets very chaotic it could end up
like in Taiwan chines people need to be
controlled otherwise they will do
whatever they want whether you agree or
disagree with Chan's beliefs one thing's
for certain he knows how to get pules
racing no matter where his fans fall on
the political
Spectrum from embodying country music
icon Johnny Cash and walk the line down
to his distinctive singing voice to the
vicious sadism of the emperor in
Gladiator walking Phoenix has proven
that his range is virtually unmatched
but his rise to fame was neither assured
nor
straightforward born Wen Raphael botom
on October 28th 1974 in Puerto Rico
Phoenix had nomadic early years as his
parents were members of the children of
God Christian Missionary group now
classified as a cult because of their
involvement in that organization the
bottoms traveled all over South and
Central America until the Cults
increasingly Sinister practices
including alleged sexual abuse and
incest began to disenchant Walken's
parents after escaping children of God
and returning to the US with their five
kids in toe the bottoms eventually
settled in Los Angeles they changed
their last name from bottom to Phoenix
and Wen also decided to go by the first
name Leaf so he could better match with
his brother River and their sister
summer rain and Liberty the Phoenix kids
played music on the streets for rent
money until their mom Arland AKA Harts
got a job as a secretary to an NBC
casting agent through her networking a
well-known casting agent was won over by
the family's talent and shepherded them
in to the bright lights of Hollywood
walking Phoenix went by his chosen name
Lee for the first few years of his
acting career but it was actually his
brother who snagged the first screen
roll in the television series Seven
Brides for Seven Brothers River quickly
brought his family along Wen had his
first TV rooll on that show too
immediately followed by a string of
small roles on TV as River star began to
rise in movies with his breakout and
standby me Wen also landed juicy lead
roles in space camp in 1986 and ruskies
in 1987 stay put with next hour so
nobody will get hurt Walken's first
truly Big Break wouldn't come until 1989
with the Steve Martin family dramedy
Parenthood as troubled youngster Gary a
boy struggling with his father's
abandonment of his family the film was a
hit and Phoenix was nominated for a
young artist Award for best leading
young actor for this nuanced and
heartbreaking performance he didn't
think it was such a good idea oh sweet I
better go but just as waen was set to
follow in his brother's successful
footsteps another tragedy hit his family
that prevented Ed him from acting for
almost 2 years on Halloween night in
1993 waen Phoenix was at Hollywood
nightclub The Viper Room when his
brother River overdosed on a cocktail of
drugs Wen was the one who called 911
while their sister rain tried to
resuscitate River using CPR River later
died at the hospital a trauma that
impacted waen and the Phoenix family
immeasurably waen was only 19 his
brother had recently turned 23 Wen
Phoenix was so devastated by his
brother's sudden death that he didn't
act for almost 2 years by this time
wen's parents had split up and his
father John had moved back to South
America while wen's mom and sisters
retreated to their family property in
Florida and the safety of their
connection and privacy to mourn and heal
Wen went to live and travel with his
father instead while Keen Phoenix was
hit extremely hard losing his brother
River but when he came back to acting he
did so with a Vengeance he decided to
return to his given name Wen instead of
leaf seen for the first time in the
credits of Gus Van sans's critically
acclaimed film to die for which
kickstarted a fierce chapter of
Phoenix's career in
1995 now I take it very serious after
the success of toai for Phoenix went on
to work with Oliver Stone on U-turn then
went on to the romantic drama inventing
the Abbotts and The Thrillers clay
pigeons and 8mm but it wasn't until
Ridley Scott's Gladiator that Phoenix's
talents brought him his first Oscar
nomination for his layered performance
as Emperor comus by the time he worked
with M Night Shyamalan on signs and the
village Phoenix had become a
full-fledged movie star while wiing
Phenix Phoenix's earlier roles were each
marked with singular iterations of
Phoenix's profound emotional depth he
took things to a new level with his
method acting and walked the line in
2005 embodying Johnny Cash down to his
singing voice and earning a Grammy as
well as a Golden Globe for his
tremendous work diving deep emotionally
and physically to embody Johnny Cash and
the addictions that shaped his life and
career would also come with a dark side
for walking Phoenix after filming for
Walk the Line wrapped he checked himself
into rehab for a brief stint Phoenix had
never been more than a soci Drinker
before Walked the Line and had increased
his alcohol consumption significantly to
better understand cash as he told London
magazine I was really leaning on alcohol
to feel okay that's really what it was
during this difficult time Phoenix also
had a terrifying brush with death when
his brakes failed and his car crashed
amazingly he was rescued by documentary
filmmaker verer Herzog and nobody was
badly injured from 2009 to 2010 the
public at large was worried about
walking Phoenix wondering if he was on
drugs or worse when he announced his
retirement from acting to become a
rapper this period was marked with
Phoenix behaving erratically in
interviews and talk shows like his now
famous David Letterman appearance all of
which would turn out to be an elaborate
piece of performance art directed by
Phoenix's then brother-in-law Casey
Affleck that was eventually turned into
the mockumentary I'm still here these
guys have seen the worst of me they've
seen the best they've seen the honest
I'm not trying after this odd detour
Phoenix went on to stun audiences and
critics with his role as Freddy quell
and Paul Thomas Anderson's the master
which earned his third Oscar nomination
he also starred in Spike Jones's
strangely poignant Tech oriented dramedy
her as a lonely man who falls in love
with his computer operating system to
name just one standout role he's had in
his post-performance art years riding a
wave of critical Acclaim for his
performance in the comics inspired 2019
drama Joker walking Phoenix received the
Toronto International Film Festival
tribute actor award alongside Merill
Street the award recognizes Decades of
cinematic excellence and during his
acceptance speech Wen made rare and
emotional comments about his late
brother River saying when I was 15 or 16
my brother River came home from work and
he had a VHS copy of a movie called
raging bowl and he sat me down and made
me watch it and the next day he woke me
up and he made me watch it again and he
said you're going to start acting again
this is what you're going to do he
didn't ask me he told me and I'm
indebted to him for that because acting
has given me such an incredible life
Phoenix also credited his father John
for gifting him with an exceptional work
ethic that helped get him to this point
but also quip that it might not have
been fully on dis play on The Joker
set even after years in the spotlight
there's still a lot of mystery to Sasha
Baron Cohen and much about the comic
many casual viewers wouldn't know here's
a look at some of the most interesting
and least known bits and pieces about
Baron Cohen's life Baron Cohen wanted to
be a performer since childhood having
been mostly influenced by actor and
comedian Peter sers Baron Cohen told the
guardian he was this incredibly
realistic actor who was also hilarious
and who managed to bridge the gap
between comedy and satire it's an easy
influence to understand sellers who
claimed he had no personality outside
his characters wouldn't just act his
roles he' become them
sir I have a
plan I can walk when he was 12 Baron
Cohen formed a break dancing troop
specifically so they could perform at
his bar mitzvah during his teenage years
he wrote and performed many sketches as
part of a youth group including one with
his brothers the schvitzing brothers
Baron Cohen described the sketch on the
podcast WTF with Mark Maron saying it
was about how these hidic Jews get so
hot that they end up shaving their
beards and taking their clothes off and
actually converting to Christianity at
the end and it would go down terribly I
mean these old age homes would hate it
in college Baron Cohen joined foot
lights Cambridge University's theater
Club after graduating he gave himself 5
years to make it as a performer and
spent some time working for small TV
stations where he developed a character
who' later become Ali G while he doesn't
consider himself particularly religious
Baron Cohen's Jewish identity is a large
part of his limited public Persona he
keeps Shabbat when he can not working
Friday evening through Saturday evening
and attends synagogue a few times a year
he also keeps kosher whenever possible
once grilling a waiter about an
appetizer during a rolling stone
interview to make sure there was no
shellfish or pork his Jewish identity
goes beyond tradition observances Baron
Cohen worked at a kibuts in Northern
Israel during a gap year before
University he wrote his undergraduate
thesis on the alliance between black
groups and Jewish people during the
Civil Rights Movement traveling America
and using the adl's archives to complete
his research he also speaks fluent
Hebrew the language he actually uses
when playing Borat yes that's right a
famously anti-semitic character is
speaking Hebrew five
five Borat isn't just a funny character
Baron Cohen sees him as a means to an
end he's not just showing that people
have intolerant views he's showing that
many are indifferent a far more
dangerous trait this is best illustrated
by the Ali G Show's most infamous
segment Borat singing the song in my
country there is problem at a bar in
Tucson Arizona by the end of the song
most of the bar is clapping and cheering
Baron Cohen told Rolling Stone Borat
essentially works as a tool by himself
being anti-semitic he lets people l or
their guard and expose their own
Prejudice whether it's anti-Semitism or
an acceptance of
anti-Semitism what is the best gun to
defend from a Jew I would uh recommend
either a 9 mm or a 45 he recognized that
the in my country there is problem
sketch was controversial but that helped
prove his point to me it revealed
something about that bar in Tucson and
the question is did it reveal that they
were anti-semitic perhaps but maybe it
just revealed that they were indifferent
to to anti-Semitism this assertion was
reinforced when the forward reached out
to the country west manager who said The
only thing we were told was that he was
from Kaka kakan or something the bar
supervisor told Tucson Weekly that she
wasn't worried saying you see worse
things on TV and there are bigger issues
to address it's easy to divide Sasha
Baron Cohen's career into pre- Borat and
post Borat but that misses a more
specific Milestone by his own estimation
winning the Golden Globe for Borat was
the moment his career changed Baron
Cohen was given the award over Heavy
Hitters and established actors like
Johnny Depp and Aaron eckart he then
spent almost his entire speech talking
about the movie's Infamous naked fight
scene likely the only time the phrase
anus and testicles were said at the
Golden Globes but even though he made a
joke out of the victory for him it was
no joke Baron Cohen told the Toronto
Star that winning quote broke me out
from being just a pure comedian into
something larger the award was Pro
positive that there was a performance
behind Borat it helped spearhead a
serious acting career that saw Baron
Cohen work with Martin scorsi and Tim
Burton not long after Dawning the gray
suit one of the first real prestigious
roles Baron Cohen took on post Borat was
station inspector Gustav in Martin
scorsese's Hugo after working largely in
comedy Baron Cohen didn't know what to
expect telling Georgia Straight I
expected him to be an aour and he is but
I think that part of his power and the
reason why films are so successful is
that he is ready to collaborate fully
with his actors the two men work
together on fleshing out Gustav the
script originally just mentioned that
Gustav had a fixation with catching
children and sending them to the
orphanage but Baron Cohen wanted to find
a motive for these actions and pitched
that he might be a war veteran see I was
injured in the war and it will never
heal good evening Melle Baron Cohen
pitched several scenes himself as well
including the one when his character
takes a bath with a the dog he said of
scorsi he was totally ready to try out
any idea however ludicrous the
suggestion which was worrying to the
producers Baron Cohen attended the 2012
Oscars red carpet in character as
Admiral General aladine to promote the
dictator he carried around an N that he
claimed contained the ashes of Kim Jong
ill in a moment that made headlines
around the world he then spilled the
ashes on Ryan seest during an interview
before being escorted away what's less
known about that moment do you think
that I'm lucky is that is this a vision
of luck CEST wasn't the original Target
the E correspondent gave more insight
into the incident on his radio show
later that year saying he ran into Baron
Cohen's wife Isa fiser backstage at
Saturday Night Live and she apologized
for her husband Baron Cohen was doing a
walk-on Cameo as aladine for a weekend
update segment and as soon as the
segment was over he ran over to CEST and
broke character to apologize CEST
explained originally he said that they
were going to spill whatever it was in
that ear on George Clooney someone
decided that wasn't a great idea because
he was up for a lot of nominations it
was a big night that night then they
somehow spun the wheel of tragedy and
landed on my name he was out they going
to do that to me or George Clooney right
Ramy Malik's Oscar winning turn as
Freddy Mercury has led many to forget
that Sasha Baron Cohen was attached to
star in a queen biopic for years between
Baron Cohen's ability to get lost in a
role and borat's Mercury esque mustache
the casting almost made too much sense
he signed on around 2010 and departed in
2013 after he and the surviving members
of Queen couldn't agree on the movie's
Direction band members suggested that
Baron Cohen was either too recognizable
or they had worries the movie would
become a joke 3 years later both sides
aired more specific grievances in detail
publicly during an interview with Howard
Stern in March of 2016 Baron Cohen
claimed that an unnamed member of Queen
said said Freddy would die halfway
through the movie the second half would
be quote seeing how the band Carries On
from strength to strength not one person
is going to see a movie where the lead
character dies from eight and then you
carry on Freddy in his estimation had
too many amazing and often obscene
stories to die off mid movie but Queen
quote wanted to protect their legacy as
a band Brian May responded via an
interview with Daily Mail a month later
he accused Baron Cohen of lying to the
Press denying that they wanted to quote
sugarcoat the band's history and said we
decided he wasn't right for the role for
very good reasons which will become
apparent if you watch what he's done
recently guys guys we've got to carry on
no character in Baron Cohen's Showtime
series who is America was darker than
Gio monaldo a billionaire playboy who
dove into the most vile parts of society
he managed to get a lot of awful people
to to agree to awful things Baron Cohen
revealed to deadline however that there
was one interview that went too far even
for him Baron Cohen wanted to find out
how guys like Harvey Weinstein got away
with criminal Behavior as Gio he
interviewed a Las Vegas concierge who
claimed to have worked for billionaires
and politicians during the interview Gio
implied that he had molested an
8-year-old boy and fully expected the
concierge to walk out instead he stayed
and offered to put Gio in touch with a
lawyer who could silence the boy the
interview ended darker still Gio asked
for a date to be arranged with a boy and
the concierge said he had a contact who
could do it the production team
immediately handed the footage over to
the FBI given that they might have just
uncovered a child sex trafficking ring
in Las Vegas despite the outrageous
nature of the footage Baron Cohen had
seen more than enough and decided not to
include it in the series saying it was
too dark and wrong in a journalistic way
it was fascinating but it was so extreme
and so dark that it was too unsettling
for the audience Baron Cohen often gets
sued over his work but the suits almost
never succeed anyone interviewed famous
or Layman sign legal releases that
prevent them from bringing claims
against the producers even if the
interview itself is deceptive the target
has ample opportunity to review the
release public figures have even more of
an uphill battle the burden of proof for
defamation is much higher for the
already famous and famous people can't
exactly defame themselves even lawsuits
for fraud are likely to backfire as
entertainment lawyer John Rosenberg told
the New York Times if I come on to a
television show believing that it's a
serious political issues oriented format
instead of this sort of satirical
presentation and I make a racist or
misogynistic comment Sasha Baron Cohen
didn't defraud me into making that
statement our women you're slaves in
Russia no do you have a slaves here we
wish no slaves W there was however one
case when Baron Cohen's Camp was in the
wrong in Bruno the Title Character
interviews aan abua a Palestinian man
labeled as a leader of militia group al-
AXA martyr brigades this was a lie abua
is a Christian Palestinian a grosser by
trade a non-violent activist by choice
and has no association with any
paramilitary groups abua sued seeking
damages and unlike everyone else had a
case Bruno never used used Abu aa's own
words against him and labeled him
incorrectly without his consent the suit
was later settled to the mutual
satisfaction of all parties Baron Cohen
introduced JoJo rabbit at the 2020
Golden Globes by saying the hero of this
next movie is a naive misguided child
who spreads Nazi propaganda and only has
imaginary friends his name is Mark
Zuckerberg after some shocked laughs he
joked that was the leftover intro to The
Social Network this made headlines but
is only the tip of the iceberg with
regard to Baron Cohen's battle against
social media and its complicity in
spreading fake information Baron Cohen
has long called for greater government
regulation of social media the most
prominent example of this was his
acceptance speech after being given the
adl's International Leadership award in
November of 2019 he spoke about the
dangerous indifference of Facebook
Google alphabet Youtube and Twitter the
six main owners of which he named the
Silicon 6 he broke down in detail how
just a handful of companies have become
quote the greatest propaganda machine in
history and said its entire business
model relies on generating more
engagement and nothing generates more
engagement than lies fear and outrage
Baron Cohen saved most of his ire for
Zuckerberg who'd spoken out against
regulation of social media the previous
month and said that while he found
Holocaust denial disgusting he wouldn't
remove it from Facebook because people
get things wrong it's like we're living
in the Roman Empire and Mark Zuckerberg
is Caesar at least that would explain
his haircut Baron Cohen was so serious
about this that he later got the speech
published in the Washington Post Sasha
Baron Cohen makes much of his living by
irritating people which means that he's
put in a lot of dangerous situations the
MMA scene at the end of Bruno saw a
crowd yell slurs and throw chairs at him
and he only survived the incident by
escaping through a trap door the rodeo
scene in Borat was even more hostile
than depicted in the film a
contemporaneous report from the Rowan
Oak time claims that the booing was so
loud that the front office staff could
hear it a rodeo producer realized the
situation was a hoax of some sort so he
escorted everyone out and advised them
to leave before a riot started a setup
in who is America saw Baron Cohen pitch
the largest mosque outside the Middle
East to a racist crowd in Kingman
Arizona Baron Cohen outlined three
precautions audiences had to check
weapons a bodyguard was on site and
Baron Cohen himself was given a
bulletproof clipboard the production of
Borat subsequent movie film was his most
dangerous yet and not just because of
the pandemic he wrote in time that he
wore a bulletproof vest while performing
at a 3er rally he rushed to his getaway
car after organizers stormed the stage
only to have his car surrounded and the
door pulled open before he escaped you
really give 100 maybe even 30% for these
films I mean it is yeah I'm probably I
have probably a mental
problem on May 21st 2023 Ray Stevenson
died at the age of 58 the news Rock the
entertainment industry in celebration of
the actor's career and life let's take a
look back at the late Ray Stevenson when
the shocking news of Ray Stevenson's
death was announced many of his co-stars
and friends took to social media where
they posted heartfelt tributes to the
northern Irish actor on Instagram Ahsoka
Star Rosario Dawson shared several
photos of her with Stevenson on set
writing a giant of a man stunned and
reeling from this tragic devastating
news Gone Too Soon from this world at a
loss for words just wanted to mark this
moment and share your ever ready and
presence smile love you forever
Stephenson was a complex and
unconventional action hero whose path to
movie and TV stardom was anything but
ordinary that being said he always
exhibited enthusiasm and appreciation
for his work the process and what he
ultimately achieved and he was quick to
share the credit with everyone in front
of the camera and behind the scenes
who'd been a part of his acting Journey
ask any actor who their favorite
performer is and there will usually be
several answers don't be surprised
though if more than half the responses
feature the names of acclaimed Leading
Men like Marlon Brando Clark Gable and
Paul Newman as actor Cut From a
Different Cloth Ray Stevenson looked at
a different set of thespians as
inspiration telling backstage it was the
likes of Lee Marvin Jee Hackman never a
bad performance and brave and fearless
within that caliber it was never the
young hot leading man it was men who I
could identify with while impressed by
Marvin and Hackman's work the actor
stressed that it was a combination of
other elements which helped these actors
Shine On Screen Stevenson believed
actors Excel as performers when the
right creative talent and other parts of
the production is supportive and
provides the necessary tools for success
to quote the horrid and cheesy corporate
approv term Teamwork Makes the Dream
Work from a notorious swashbuckling
historical pirate to Marvel's most
infamous gun tooning vigilante Ray
Stevenson brought a Litany of characters
to life in his story career either you
are
unkillable or way overdue however like
most actors he had a white whale the
dream part he chased but never quite
caught in a 2008 collider interview
Stevenson admitted his love for a
certain shakerian play saying I've
always been intrigued by cor elanus it's
potentially one of the most potent and
revealing Scripts I love the play I'd
love to do that as a movie One Day a
film adaptation of Cory elanus did
arrive in 2011 Ray fines directed
produced and starred in the movie that
received near Universal Acclaim
unfortunately Stevenson wasn't a part of
the Blockbuster cast which included the
likes of Gerard Butler Vanessa Redgrave
Jessica Chastain and Brian Cox Ray
Stevenson's most punishing role was in
Lexi Alexander's Punisher war zone
released in 2008 this reboot boasts
blood guts and more R-rated violence
than the average superhero movie
Stevenson dazzles as Frank Castle
embodying the Vigilante from the brutal
Punisher comic book
series see you in hell I see you
anywhere near hell I'll kick your ass up
unfortunately Punisher war zone neither
lit up the box office nor inspired
critics to get skull tattoos on their
biceps but despite the film's
underwhelming financial and critical
performance it eventually became a cult
classic in a chat with Stevenson for the
action Elite writer David J Moore
expressed his dismay that the actor
never had a chance to return to the role
of Castle Stevenson agreed saying so was
I write in and tell them that I would in
a heartbeat go back I love the storyline
and the comic books that it was based on
it could definitely do with the sequel
sadly this never happened as Netflix
rebooted Punisher as a series with
Walking Dead Star John Bernthal as the
titular character the Marvel Cinematic
Universe or MCU kickstarted in May 2008
with the release of John fabos Iron Man
while not considered a part of the
official MCU Punisher war zone arrived
that December considering Frank Castle's
significance in the greater Marvel
Universe Ray Stevenson found himself in
an odd situation would his character
eventually be incorporated into the MCU
or would he be cast in a different role
in the franchise the lad seemed highly
unlikely until Kenneth bro's 2011 movie
Thor in which Stevenson debuted as volag
a member of asgard's Warriors 3 team in
an interview with the AV club Stevenson
expressed surprise at the way events
unfolded saying what a great privilege
for Marvel because they have kind of an
Unwritten rule that once you play one of
their major protagonists or characters
in order to maintain a certain degree of
Integrity for Their audience you don't
get to do it again well not a major role
like The Punisher of vol stag appears in
the first three Thor films played by
Stevenson each time as one of the most
popular TV shows of all time HBO's Game
of Thrones changed the lives of its cast
members making them household names but
no one predicted the Epic Fantasy
series's game-changing success when it
first began production consequently many
actors turned down roles on the show and
Ray Stevenson was one of them in 2015
Stevenson revealed to movie.com that he
had the opportunity to join the Game of
Thrones cast but turned it down
admitting the show was already too far
down the line for me I would rather have
been involved in the growth of a show
Even though everyone gets pumped off
left right and Center Stevenson didn't
disclose the role he was offered so as
not to take away from the actor who
ultimately played the part he did say it
would have kept him busy from anywhere
from 4 to 6 months but he'd already
agreed to play Blackbeard on stars'
black sales in Showbiz actors and
directors receive all the praise when
action scenes Go full throttle however
stunt performers are the unheralded
heroes of Cinema it's the stunt doubles
who perform the death defying dangerous
sequences that make a movie and its
actors look good for the audience
Stevenson made a lot of action films and
worked with many stunt Specialists
across his various projects speaking to
comingsoon.net he praised the Daredevils
for putting their bodies on the line
singling out Rob Mars who doubled for
him in several movies Stevenson also
discussed the process of working with
the stunt doubles peeling back the
curtain of movie Magic to explain how
the transition between actor and double
occurs he explained when you have a
stunt man and this is his discipline you
go right up to the stunt itself and then
act during the stunt so you have this
overlap and I involved them in my
process the northern Irish born star
expressed a high level of respect for
what stunt teams do adding that he
developed personal friendships with many
of them over the years John M Chu's gii
Joe retaliation hit the big screen in
2013 while build is the sequel to 2009's
gi. Joe the Rise of Cobra the film
largely focuses on a new group of Heroes
led by Dwayne Johnson's road block in
the opposite corner stands Ray Stevenson
as firefly an explosive villain who
works with the Sinister Cobra making
more things go boom by 9:00 a.m. and
most people do all day naturally as the
two big men on the film roadblock and
Firefly eventually battle each other in
a Clash of the Titans during the filming
of gi. Joe retaliation an encounter
between Stevenson and Johnson left one
of them a bloody mess in an interview
with the Daily Record Stevenson recalled
the worst moment was when we filmed the
first big fight I spun round and
accidentally caught him right across the
bridge of his nose I drew blood and I
was worried but Dwayne just Shrugged it
off he was great about it and just said
these things happen Stevenson added how
the intensity and physicality of their
action scenes resulted in numerous
bruises throughout production and
admitted that Johnson ended up popping
him on the nose as well in the world of
pro wrestling that's referred to as a
receipt due to his height and rugged
good looks Ray Stevenson was often cast
as physically formidable characters and
mostly action Centric Productions the
fact that so many fans still consider
him the quintessential version of The
Punisher is evidence of his powerful
reputation as an on-screen tough guy
aren't you quite vicious my dear yet
Stevenson surpris viewers with his work
in different genres when the opportunity
arose for example he received praise for
his turn as Roger Wesley and Adam
McKay's cop comedy the other gu which
also starred will frell and Mark walber
speaking with the AV club Stevenson
gushed about the experience of working
with comedians like frell and revealed
that M called him a few days before
camera started to roll to suggest his
character speak with an Australian
accent the actor obliged Stevenson
enjoyed the opportunity to exercise his
sense of humor saying I love doing
comedy I always maintain that there's
humor in everything Ray Stevenson's
journey to becoming an actor was the
furtherest thing from conventional he
was already 25 when he realized it was
something he wanted to pursue eventually
graduating from the Bristol old vict
theater school at 29 a notable Talent he
worked his way up the ranks achieving
mainstream recognition thanks to his
role as Dagan in 2004's King Arthur his
big breakthrough came a year later when
he was cast in the lead role of Titus
pulo in the HBO limited series Rome from
there his career took off and the film
offers flooded in surprisingly Stevenson
didn't become a member of The Screen
Actors Guild American Federation of
television and radio artists or sag
aftera until later in his acting career
speaking to Backstage Stephenson
revealed how Rome helped him earn the
coveted Union card saying over the
course of two seasons I created quite a
bit of interest and that gave me my
representation in the states and airo
started my movie career at 44 which is
almost unheard of it's remarkable to
consider how Stevenson worked on a
blockbuster like King Arthur without
being a part of the Union throughout his
career Ray Stevenson shared the screen
with numerous bigname Stars including
Dwayne Johnson clyve Owen and Chris
Hemsworth as is the case in most lines
of work co-workers end up following each
other on social media occasionally
interacting but also getting hard blocks
if they rat you out to the boss in 200
15 ucks asked Stevenson who his favorite
person to follow online was the actor
replied a Japanese actor I worked with
on Thor asano tadanobu he's involved in
three or four rock bands has his own
online fashion brand and includes photos
of his latest looks from whatever
project he's working on and he posts
sketch cartoons which are great in
2011's Thor asano portrayed the part of
Hogan one of the Warriors 3 and he
returned to the role for the next two
sequels the Japanese actor also appeared
as Lord Kira in 2013's 47 Ronin and the
God of Thunder Raiden in 202 's Mortal
Kombat movie from Titus pulo in Rome to
Danny Green and Kelly Irishman and
Blackbeard and black sales Ray Stevenson
showed an act for portraying historical
figures on screen as a result the
industry and audiences Associated him
with period pieces and he appeared to
gravitate toward those types of projects
more than others in an interview with
geeks worldwide Stevenson confessed I
consider myself a historical nerd and
clearly see the correlation between
these historical figures and the massive
changes that the world was undergoing
with the spread of civilization and the
reach of England in the same interview
the actor also revealed how he believed
history had been distorted by
sensationalism such as the pamphlets and
stories of pirates like Blackbeard he
actually seems to have been a fairly
intelligent man a good leader a bold
dangerous pirate however as an actor
researching a role he would seek out the
kernels of Truth in each account and
then try to look at the story from his
character's unique perspective coupled
with the demands of the script one of
Stevenson's last completed films before
he died was the historical drama Gateway
to the West which centers on real life
events in which the Mongolian Army
invaded Hungary
Ray Stevenson achieved a unique
distinction in the Star Wars Universe by
portraying two different characters if
car Saxon could see you
now I know right the actor voiced gar
Saxon in the animated show Star Wars of
Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels while
also playing balent skull in the live
action Ahsoka series the latter sees
Stevenson living every Fan's biggest
dream of wielding a lightsaber and going
toe-to-toe with Rosario Dawson's ahoka
Tano Stevenson recognized the magnitude
and importance of stepping into the
Beloved Star Wars franchise speaking to
entertain at weekly he revealed the
intense preparation and dedication that
went into his portrayal of Balin while
praising the environment and hard work
that his collaborators put into making
the Disney plus series come to life on a
personal level Stevenson couldn't help
it get caught up in the moments when he
picked up a lightsaber for the first
time he confided to Entertainment Weekly
I must admit the first time you turn a
lightsaber on you make the noise and
then you're like oh I'm so sorry
everybody does that but you just can't
help it even after he established
himself in Blockbusters Stevenson
occasionally popped up in unexpected
films one of his more out of the blue
roles came in 2018s action film accident
Man based on the comic written by Pat
Mills and Tony Skinner and illustrated
by a variety of artists the filmar Scott
Atkins is Mike Fallon an assassin who
possesses the ability to make his hits
look like accidents never get
angry never get
involved and most importantly never get
C Stevenson plays Fallon's mentor and
Father Figure big Ray Atkins and Stevens
reprised their parts for the 2022 sequel
accident Man hitman's Holiday Atkins who
was also the producer and co-writer of
the films revealed to the Hollywood news
that the role of big Ray was conceived
with Stevenson in mind saying he was
always on the list and he was the first
guy we went out to and the first guy we
got that was a great coup we need
someone who is a great actor and someone
who can sign on and help us Finance the
movie so for those who watched and
enjoyed the accident Man franchise you
owe Stevenson a debt of gratitude for
adding his star power to the project
thanks to his versatility as an actor
and desire to spread his wings Ray
Stevenson appeared in everything from
historical pieces to big budget
blockbusters this afforded him the
opportunity to Star alongside a wealth
of extraordinary Talent such as Anthony
Hopkins and Renee Russo and Thor denel
Washington and Gary Oldman in the Book
of Eli and Samuel L Jackson in big game
during the Press junket for big game
Stevenson revealed to topless robot that
he didn't get over AED by the stars with
whom he shared the screen no matter how
famous they were he found them to be
professionals like him who were there to
serve the movie not their egos he went
on to say it just appears to be such a
great warm cuddly teddy bear feeling is
the fact that the bigger they are the
more open and giving and con timately
professional actors are and there's
fearlessness Stevenson explained that in
his experience the more experienced
actors weren't afraid to change things
up in the middle of scenes to figure out
what worked best for the film more
importantly they never tried to outshine
or upstage others choosing to be
collaborators with their focus always
remaining on the best way to elevate the
film in question although there was no
direct sequel to Lexi Alexander's
Punisher war zone Ray Stevenson did get
another chance at running a muck as
Frank Castle albeit in a more
family-friendly manner he lent his voice
to the animated version of The Punisher
that appears in the Superhero Squad Show
we're nothing but white blood cells
hunting the infection called crime a
sickness that sneaks in through the
cracks he voices the character in the
same gritty way he played him in the
live action movie leaving the other more
fun-loving Heroes shocked at how intense
he is undoubtedly Stevenson's straight
delivery adds to the comedic effect of
his scenes as he becomes almost but not
quite a parody of Marvel's edgy
anti-hero and his bloodlust for
vengeance speaking about the role to the
AB Club Stevenson opened up more about
the experience saying it was strange I
went up to a studio somewhere in LA and
voiced over all these lines I haven't
even seen it but yeah apparently it's
out there in the wonderful world well he
may not have seen the fruits of his
labor he jumped at the opportunity to
play The Punisher again as a result of
the experience Stevenson admitted to a
keen interest in doing more voice acting
he done a bit of it in London when he
was a young actor however he knew the
timing would be tough to work out with
his busy movie and television career
when actors are asked about their
favorite performance I'll often tell the
interviewer it's their current one much
the same way a musician always says
their new song or album is their best
work ever but Ray Stevenson decided on a
different approach when he spoke to
journalist Arthur Kade during the Press
tour for black sales instead of
declaring the pirate series to be his
greatest accomplishment to date
Stevenson cited Rome not only because it
was a project that elevated him to
superstardom but for personal reasons as
well Stevenson recalled it has to be
Rome that was one of the major major
periods of my life it turned my life
around I found my partner who was my
landl Stevenson joked about how
elizabetha karacha raised his rent even
after they became a couple while telling
the story about how his work on the the
series LED to them living together
having three children and a dog he also
explained that while he was working on
Rome he learned to look in acting from
an entirely New Perspective instead of
second guessing himself or trying too
hard to remember what was next he
shifted his mindset and focus completely
on what was in front of him and his
character in that moment this changed
the way he approached his work from
there on out in season 7 of Dexter Ray
Stevenson turns in a memorable
performance as the mobster Isaac CCO who
Wants Revenge on Dexter Morgan for
killing his lover Victor bosov I run one
of the biggest crimes syndicates in the
Caucasus who is T to Morgan it's a very
different kind of role from any he'd
played before which is exactly the
reason the actor agreed to do it in an
interview with Yahoo Stevenson talked
about receiving a call from Dexter
producer and writer Scott buck with whom
he'd worked on Rome Buck explained how
the CCO character would fit into the
overall Arc of the show as well as his
underlying motivations all of which
fascinated Stevenson Stevenson went on
to explain Ciro was a Cold Stone mobster
a killer with a secret but he's
basically a man whose heart has been
ripped out of his body Stevenson added
how Ciro gave up up everything including
ultimately his life in his quest for
vengeance because he loved bosov with
all his heart considering Ray
Stevenson's affinity for historical
dramas was anyone really surprised when
he was eventually cast as the wandering
sailor oot ter and Vikings he appears in
11 episodes of Vikings season six of
course Stevenson possessed some prior
relevant experience of sorts having
portrayed a space Viking in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe however as Stevenson
revealed to journalist Matt J horn while
discussing his work in Thor he had a
closer connection to the world of
Vikings and most people made realize
Stevenson explained I had my formative
years in the northeast of England a
place littered with Vikings and Norse
mythology indeed my father would often
tell me that the derivative of my
surname Stevenson was in fact senson a
fine old Viking name many actors love to
talk about how acting is a calling
something more than a profession and how
they do it for artistic value and
spiritual satisfaction if you get to go
to work and and you're living as an
actor you you're
done what else would you want then there
are others who in addition to the
passion they feel for the process admit
that they don't hate the fame side of
the job they can be open about enjoying
the glitz and glamour of it all as well
as the many perks of stardom such as
seeing action figures based on the
characters they portrayed Ray Stevenson
was one of those and he confessed to
having a very particular goal for his
career in an interview with Bill during
the Press tour for the transporter
refueled Stevenson revealed it was a
dream of mine one day to have an action
figure he couldn't understand how anyone
wouldn't be excited about the idea while
expressing his delight at having not one
but three action figures out in the
world the actor joked that he couldn't
get too carried away with himself though
because his children brought him back
down to earth in fact his kids had
ripped the heads off his action figures
and one of them even replaced his dad's
head with a Lego one while Stevenson
didn't say which figure his child
recapitate he had a good laugh about the
whole thing Ray Stevenson's death deeply
affected his former co-stars especially
his fellow Ahsoka castmates since a
Disney plus series was one of his final
projects before his passing in fact
Ahsoka even includes a tribute to
Stevenson in the closing credits of the
first episode part one master and
Apprentice in an interview with people
Rosario Dawson remembered Stevenson and
his powerful performances balen skull
but she also took the time to praise him
as a special and kind human being
recalling he'd have these crystals that
had all these different meanings from
where you know he felt like spiritually
where he came from and what he wanted to
be resonating and we'd sit and have
these conversations about the divine
feminine Dawson went on to say that he
was a fascinating and thoughtful
individual to talk to as he loved to
discuss philosophy and his
family from his early days with
Britain's National swim team to his
current status as one of the world's
most bable movie stars Jason Stam has
lived an interesting life if you want to
learn more about the iconic English
Action Hero here's the Untold Truth of
Jason Statham if Jason Statham is
starring in a movie you best believe
that there's going to be some action
involved whether it's an adrenaline
pumping car chase a bullet spraying
shootout or a good old-fashioned
barehanded Beatdown the action star
seems to feed off of stunt work and more
often than not Stam is actually the one
performing the stunts too as he
explained to IGN I'll do more if they
let me me I've never really been
frightened to do anything in an
interview with the guardian the train
Sporter star talked about how his early
ambition of becoming a stuntman was
initially sparked by watching a man
doing a high dive into a hotel pool
saying he'd done this sort of reverse
layout and I was like I'd love to do
that years later the young Daredevil had
mastered the craft of diving and he was
even selected to compete for the British
national team in the 1990 Commonwealth
Games although Stam ultimately retired
from the sport perhaps his intense
diving training helped hone his body for
the demanding stunt work that his film
career would bring a lot of today's
biggest actors and actresses were taught
how to hone their craft through years of
studying drama or performing in
prestigious theat Productions Jason STM
however apparently has a bit of a
different origin story than your typical
aiser when speaking to Esquire the crank
actor opened up about how his father
taught him to hustle on the London
streets when he was just a teenager
saying I'd sit down outside of Harold's
and I'd pitch the jewelry and when I'm
selling is costume jewelry basically but
I'm selling it with a bit of Street
Theater and having a bit of fun with it
making a living an actor is nothing if
not a skilled salesman right Stan went
on to boast that he was such a talented
Hustler that he could pull in as much as
$3,000 in a weekend so what did the
future Fast and Furious stars say he'd
spend all that dough on would buy cars
and with race cars I've always loved
Stam literally went from Hawking sketchy
Goods on street corners to starring and
Blockbuster action movies but throughout
it all the man's love for automobiles
has remained strong who says Bromance is
dead Jason Statham and Guy Richie the
well-renowned director of action flicks
like 2017's King Arthur legend of the
sword Prov that having a Dependable
go-to guy can be a real asset in
Hollywood the duo makeer a powerful
actor director combo joining the ranks
of other successful tag teams Richie is
actually the man responsible for jump
starting saam's acting Korea casting him
as bacon in 1998's luck stuck in Two
Smoking Barrels despite the fact that he
had had absolutely zero acting
experience as Stam explained to Esquire
Richie who had met through an earlier
modeling gig approached him about the
role because the StreetWise character
was similar to Stam saying he just
wanted someone who was authentic he said
I'm going to get someone from drama
school to do this how can they learn
what you've learned after luckstar and
Two Smoking Barrels the two collaborated
again in 2000 snatch and 2005's revolver
in an interview with Yahoo entertainment
the Sherlock Holmes director had nothing
but kind words for his British BFF as he
put it Jason Stam is one of my most
favorite people in the entire world he's
grumpy and he's one of the few grumpy
people that doesn't annoy me in any way
in 1986 Nestle Executives introduced the
world to one of the catchiest
commercials in American history give me
a break give me a break break me off a
piece of that Kit Kat bar but over in
the UK candy lovers were more familiar
with a different slogan one that went
have a break have a kit kat the the
catchphrase lasted for 47 years up until
the early 2000s when a company
spokesperson announced a change in their
Market approach part of that plan
involved a brand new slogan make the
most of your break and another piece of
that advertising campaign involved one
of England's hottest names at the time
Jason Statham riding the success of
popular films like 2002's the
transporter and 2003's The Italian Job
Stam nabbed a partnership with the candy
company making him the break philosopher
the actor starred in a total of three
ads for KitKat and the Brand's then
account director Emma Stewart Smith was
very pleased with their selection
explaining Jason Stan was the best
choice he is down to earth and credible
when telling the stories he hasn't done
ads before so people tend to listen to
him more also women fancy him and men
think he's a good bloke although they've
been around for about 20 years the
commercials are still pretty funny today
stam's love life proves that age is
nothing but a number the British stud
has stated a number of beautiful women
throughout the past few decades and most
of them have been younger than him by
double digits Stam dated English model
and media personality Kelly Brook for
seven years before ultimately Calling it
Quits in 2004 he then spent nearly a
year with former Bachelor red Starlet
Sophie Monk before getting serious with
Alex zosman who hadd go on to date until
early 2010 after he and zosman parted
ways the Expendable star was spotted out
with former Victoria Secret Angel Rosie
Huntington Whitley despite their 20-year
age difference the pair who got engaged
in 2016 have now been going strong for
over 10 years Sylvester Stallone's
Expendables movies don't exactly shy
away from killing the total kill count
in the 2010 original Tes up to 221
deaths a number that's more than doubled
in its explosive sequel 2012 The
Expendables 2 for the third installment
in the grizzly franchise Jason Stam
apparently nearly wound up on the kill
count in real life after a dangerous
stunt went arai when speaking to the
mirror at the expendable 3 premiere in
2014 14 Stallone told the tale of how
his co-star had a very close call during
the film's production saying he faced
death he was test driving a 3-ton truck
and the brakes run out Stam doing his
own stunts per usual crashed The Runaway
vehicle into the Black Sea according to
Stallone if it had been anyone else
driving the truck they most likely would
have died saying we would have drowned
but because Jason is an Olympic quality
diver he got out of it years later Stan
recalled the near-death experience
during an interview with the red bullet
noting how it changed his attitude it's
a real recalibration of everything from
that day on I've been so appreciative of
life and being able to walk on the
ground I think we all need an experience
like that one that puts things in
perspective unlike some of the action
heroes he's portrayed on the big screen
Stam seemingly understands that he's not
Invincible Jason stam's filmography
proves that he's always up for joining a
multi-film franchise in addition to the
wildly popular Expendables and Fast and
Furious cinematic universes he's also
filmed a number of of sequels to his own
films such as Transporter 2 and three
Crank 2 high voltage and mechanic
Resurrection strangely enough there's
one multi-billion dollar entity that the
British bad boy opted out of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe when speaking to den
of geek in 2017 Marvel boss Kevin feige
confirmed that he had once considered
Stam for a role in the MCU but
scheduling conflicts kept it from
happening feige had nothing but nice
things to say of the action icon noting
that the actor even called him after the
fact to apologize explaining he was
saying sorry it didn't work out maybe
next time he couldn't have been nicer
the role he was considered for is
anyone's guess but some fans believe
that Stam was up for the part of
notorious Daredevil baddy Bullseye this
news was somewhat surprising considering
that Statham had made some pretty
disrespectful comments about Marvel
movies when speaking to Italian website
e400 couchi a couple years earlier
saying I could take my grandma and put
her in a cape and they'll put her on a
green screen and they'll have stun
doubles come in and do all the action
anybody can do it honestly if Statham's
grandma is anything like he is then she
probably would make a believable
superhero in 2005 thrilling Revolver
Jason ston Plays a scheming Gambler
named Jake green while in prison green
discovers a formula at game-winning
strategy with the help of two fellow
inmates a skilled comman and a chess
master and as it turns out green skills
on the chess board are apparently
something that he shares with the film
star in real life in an interview with
cinema.com Statham spoke about the
competitive relationship he has with
revolver's director and longtime friend
guy Richie noting that they are Fierce
chess Rivals a it's beautiful
man you have to admire the opponent's
Elegance check to hear him tell it he's
clearly the superior player the surface
moment is getting guy Richie to pay his
debts when he loses at chess he just
won't pay up he won't accept the loss I
have to live with that however Richie
has also playfully claim that he doesn't
respect Stam as a chess player so the
jury is still out as to which talented
celebrity is a real chess whiz in 2013's
underrated action thriller home front
Stan plays Phil broker a recently
widowed former DEA agent who moves to a
small Louisiana Town to raise his young
daughter when things go sideways and the
town's drug dealer targets the new
family it's up to broker to fend off the
bad guys and keep his kids safe Stan
plays a paternal role with great
authenticity which was perhaps an
indicator of things to come in June 2017
Statham and his fiance Rosie Huntington
Whitley welcome their firstborn son jack
Oscar to the world since then Stam has
looked every bit the part of a proud and
typical dad Young Jack certainly has a
bright future with such talented parents
to look up to when speaking to now this
the Meg's leading man opened up about
how becoming a dad truly changed his
life and reshuffled his priorities
saying you learn as soon as you become a
dad that all your selfish desires are
put on a very large back burner it's an
incredible transition and it's the
greatest feeling in the world he may be
a tough guy on screen but fatherhood
proves that Stan may have a soft side
after all I'm a big soft de and I get
told off for being too soft in 2018
thrilling shark tail the Meg Stam played
Jonas Taylor a scorned X rescue diver
with a personal Vendetta against a
mysterious massive underwater Beast that
only he believes is real when the
creature which is revealed to be a
gargantuan prehistoric shark called a
Megalodon eventually rears its ugly head
again it's up to Taylor and crew to find
it and take it down before it unleashes
an aquatic Killing Spree it's like yours
on steroids while the film's enormous
maner is only a product of CGI and bad
dreams don't get it twisted Statham
probably would have hopped in the water
even if the thing was real in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly The
Notorious English Daredevil recalled a
time when he went diving with bull
sharks in Fiji admitting that it was an
ordeal being inches away from a swarm of
the large toothy fish saying all of the
fear or the perceived fear is done in
your own head before you get down there
with them so once you're swimming down
there with all the other divers it's
phenomenal it's one of the greatest
experiences you could have for me anyway
swimming in shark infested waters is
apparently just another relaxing day in
the life of Jason
STM Mark Hamill has been a household
name for decades and while his names
become synonymous with Star Wars Luke
Skywalker undoubtedly his best known
role there's a lot more to the actor
than the moisture farmer turned space
wizard he's so often conflated with one
area in which Mark Hamill and Skywalker
are remarkably similar is in their
definitively unglamorous upbringings
though Hamill didn't grow up as the son
of Farmers on a desert Planet he was the
fourth of seven children all of whom
were ushered from location to location
as their father was stationed in various
places as a US Navy Captain though ham
had the exciting opportunity to live in
Japan for part of his youth that didn't
prevent him from starting his acting
career like so many bright-eyed young
people working at a fast food restaurant
and racking up smaller rolles in fact
Hamill was even fired from his job at a
Jack In thebox Restaurant for doing too
good an impression of the Chain's mascot
character as patrons used the
drive-through window my manager didn't
think it was very funny told me to go
home and never come back wow yeah I got
fir fired from Jack fired for being in
character this of course proved early on
that he had a knack for voicing Kookie
clowns a skill that would come in handy
a couple of decades down the line though
Luke Skywalker was his breakout role
Hamill had actually been acting since at
least 1963 when he took on a small role
in the wildly popular soap opera General
Hospital he continued to have brief
onscreen roles and TV hits of the day
including the Bill Cosby Show and The
Partridge Family things went on in this
fashion for some time with Hamill
finally Landing a few recurring
characters on the new Scooby-Doo movies
Genie and the Texas wheelers so while he
wasn't on the fast track to startom
right upon his arrival in Los Angeles he
was certainly putting in the work and
building up a substantial portfolio
something he could present to George
Lucas to seal his fate for the rest of
his life Luke Skywalker was a lucky
break but Hamill was a hardworking kid
proving that Destiny isn't the only
factor in achieving
stardom in order to combat the typ
casting that would inevitably result
from his portrayal as the wide-eyed
young hero of Destiny Luke Skywalker
Hamill branched out into other forms of
acting first as many young actors do he
spent a brief stint in the early 80s
working in Broadway plays like the
Elephant Man and Amadeus he follow
follow this endeavor with a dive head
first into voice acting as noted earlier
his pensent for Impressions and silly
voices would only Aid him further in his
career his Keen interest in comic books
helped him to land the role of the Joker
in The Beloved cartoon Batman the
Animated Series but Hamill has done work
outside cartoons as well diving into the
video game industry as a voice artist
surprise you fell for the old sick Joker
guy but
naturally some of these roles are
reprisals of his work in the Star Wars
and Batman franchises but his first
video game voice opportunity came in
1993 in the mystery thriller Gabriel
Knight sins of the fathers he's
portrayed characters in several sci-fi
military themed games like the wing
Commander series and one wonders if he
was able to pull from his experience
growing up on Naval bases it's no secret
that Hamill is a comic book fan and
thank goodness too considering he
appears at one comic convention after
another to the Delight of his adoring
fans but Hamill has also had a hand in
writing some comics of his own in the
mid99s right before the Star Wars
prequel films Hamill co-authored the
Black Pearl with his cousin Eric Johnson
the comic featuring art by hm Baker and
published by Dark Horse was a five isue
series intended to be collected into one
volume at the end of its run it follows
Luther Drake who inadvertently prevents
an abduction and continues to pursue a
life of nighttime vigilantism sounds a
bit like Batman doesn't it but it's the
post Frank Miller type of Batman dark
and conflicted and morally ambiguous the
comic was originally written as a
screenplay and as recently as 2010 haml
still had intentions to see this dark
vision brought to life on screen with
himself in the director's chair while
part of Hamill's online presence is
populated by his political thoughts he's
also dedicated a decent chunk of it to
interacting with fans he continues to
have the most delightful knack for
self-deprecating humor and a genuine
gratitude for the fans who have
supported him from the beginning or even
those newer fans who have come to Star
Wars with the newest installments of the
franchise he spends a lot of his
tweeting energy singing the Praises of
his fellow actors promoting Star Wars
related news and sharing stories of his
friendships with the likes of the late
adored Carrie Fischer Hamill is a Savvy
Twitter user in other words social media
certainly has its problems but with 3.2
million followers it's safe to say the
Force is with him when it comes to
interacting with his
audience Hamill has been married to his
wife dental hygienist Mary Lou York
since 1978 not long after the release of
a new hope the couple have three
children and one grandchild and seem to
have successfully avoided a lot of the
typical drama that Hollywood couples
tend to fall into Hamill and York's long
happy marriage is often attributed to
York's lack of celebrity they broke up
for a period so Hamill could get the
Rush of stardom out of his system but in
the end family and stability won out by
marrying a non-celebrity Hamill wasn't
competing with all of Hollywood's other
Leading Men and he married her not for
her star power or her Paparazzi appeal
but because they had a genuine
connection no doubt the two have worked
very hard at keeping their relationship
alive but it is clear that they still
love each other very much and it is
gratifying to see such a healthy
marriage flourish even as Hamill has
returned to the Hollywood Limelight with
the final installment of the Star Wars
franchises Skywalker Saga despite the
concerns about being typ cast Hamill has
done an excellent job of proving he can
have a satisfying and successful career
outside Star Wars so as the Torches
passed from Luke to Ray we see Hamill
continuing in much the same manner as
usual he Don the animated white face of
the Joker time and again in various new
animated DC series and makes guest
appearances on TV series like The Big
Bang
Theory
I'm going to need a
minute but some roles in projects stand
out more than others he put his
villainous voice to good use as the
devious doll Chucky in the 2019 film
Child's Play before taking the role of
the scientist in the Dark Crystal age of
resistance the long- hyped prequel to
Jim Henson's 1982 cult classic puppet
fueled Fantasia continuing his long
appreciation for the comics medium he's
also taken a role in Amazon's adaptation
of Robert Kirkman Cory Walker and Ryan
atley's Invincible which Chronicles the
life of the son of a superhero still in
the spotlight After All These Years Mark
Hamill has proven he has the talent to
tackle a wide variety of roles and we
can't wait to see what he does
next London born actor Robert patson
skyrocketed to fame with a massively
popular Twilight series and he recently
made headlines when it was announced
he'd be playing the titular role in the
Batman and from modeling gigs to his
sometimes dramatic love life here's
everything you need to know about Robert
patson after honing his craft in several
theater Productions Robert patson landed
his first big break at the age of 17 he
was cast as Cedric diory in the 2005
film Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire for a moment though I thought you
you were going to let it get me he chose
playing Cedric over attending University
and the film took his acting career to a
whole new level his performance was WI
widely praised and numerous Publications
hailed him as the next jeude law a label
that proved difficult to Shake in a 2008
interview with the BBC patson was asked
whether he agreed with that assessment
and he replied no you get a bit of heat
and everybody says you're this you're
that then it dies down you just do jobs
I don't know any actor who's followed
through when they say he's the next this
and then he actually has become the next
that I don't get that I don't see what
the point is the fourth Harry Potter
film put Robert patson on the map but
Twilight turned him into a household
name Patterson landed the role of Edward
Cullen in a rather roundabout way he was
in Los Angeles auditioning for a role he
assumed was already in the bag and wound
up bombing that audition in 2017 he told
W magazine and then the next day it was
the Twilight audition and I think I was
at such a kind of Nothing to Lose state
was it was quite easy for me to do and
so he was cast as an unusually sensitive
vampire Who falls in love with a young
woman named Bella portrayed by Kristen
Stewart the role earned him Legions of
fans many of them teenage girls but that
didn't stop him from mocking the
Twilight franchise in interviews my
entire performance is based on have
extreme discomfort having content l in
your eyes just like just kind of like
that if Edward was Nona fictional
character you just met him in in reality
you know he's one of those guys who'd be
like an axe murderer he also wasn't
opposed to mocking Stephanie Meyer the
author of The Twilight
novels I I was convinced that Stephanie
was convinced she was Bella and uh and
you it wasn't it was like it was a book
that wasn't supposed to be published it
sounds like patson has softened his
stance in recent years in April 2019 he
told USA Today it's lovely now that the
Mania is not so intense now the
intensity has died down and it's just
very warm
memories in May 2019 it was announced
that Robert patson would play a Young
incarnation of a certain brooding
superhero in the Batman a film that set
to Premiere in 2021 rather predictably
the news sent the Twitter verse into a
frenzy and not everyone was on board
with the idea one user wrote I've never
been so disappointed in a Batman casting
Robert patson is a horrible choice to
play the character film critic Mike
mcgranahan was clearly torn by the
casting Choice tweeting I honestly don't
know how to feel about Robert patson as
Batman on one hand I hate the idea
because I can't even remotely picture
him as the Dark Knight on the other hand
I absolutely love the idea for the exact
same reason meanwhile Jimmy Kimmel
offered this particularly hot take if
you think about it it makes sense he was
a vampire now he's a bat
and in 2012 Robert patson's relationship
with Kristen Stewart turned him into
irresistible tabloid fod though they
tried to keep the relationship Under
Wraps they were forced to come clean in
the wake of a highly publicized Scandal
Stuart finally acknowledged their
relationship after she was photographed
being intimate with then married
director Robert Sanders who worked with
Stuart on Snow White and the Huntsman
when a famous actress gets caught
cheating by the paparazzi and then makes
a very public apology G it's no surprise
people everywhere are reacting with 140
characters or less Stuart profusely
apologized in a public statement writing
this momentary indiscretion has
jeopardized the most important thing in
my life the person I love and respect
the most Rob I love him I love him I'm
so sorry Stuart and patson briefly got
back together after the Scandal but they
split for good in
2013 in 2019 patson suggested that he's
on good terms with Stuart so perhaps
this story has a happy ending after all
with his chiseled features it's not
terribly surprising that Robert patson
would try his hand at modeling he told
closer magazine that he left the
industry after 4 years at the age of 16
explaining when I first started I was
quite tall and looked like a girl so I
got lots of jobs because it was during
that period where the androgynous look
was cool then I guess I became too much
of a guy so I never got any more jobs I
had the most unsuccessful modeling
career in 2010 at the height of Twilight
fever patson was reportedly offered a
huge contract with Burberry but he
didn't take it A source told the mirror
they went to Robert but he immediately
politely turned them down as far as
Robert sees things he's an actor by
trade and that's his art he doesn't want
to start becoming a brand or anything if
that's true patson obviously had a
change of heart just a few short years
later in 2013 he became the face of DRM
and he's been working with the brand
ever
since as it turns out J law was the face
of DRM just a few years prior which
means Robert patson became the next Jude
Law after all what's he got better than
me if you only know Charlie hunam as a
badass on a Harley wait until you see
his pet cat plus why he didn't land 50
Shades of Gray or Thor all that and more
right here if you woke up one morning as
a famous actor with money to blow what's
the first thing you'd splurge on for a
ton of today's celebrities it's all
about the
Footwear hold the fudge you mean to tell
me that nobody snapped up those bad boys
Charlie hunam certainly had a shoe
obsession during the early part of his
career as well his Achilles heel Nike
Air
max90s speaking to GQ in 2013 hunam
explained that when he was a kid his
family couldn't afford to buy him
expensive shoes but when Nike reissued
the infrared colorway in the early 2000s
he couldn't resist he explained I don't
know how it happened but I became
obsessed with buying every colorway I
could get my hands on although he had
amassed a massive collection he
apparently hardly ever wore them opting
to keep most pairs in their boxes later
in a 2017 interview with L the actor
admitted that he'd grown up meaning that
his collection of kicks had to go he
said I took out six or seven pairs that
I cared about and I gave the rest to
charity it was actually a pair of shoes
that set Charlie hunam off on the the
road to fame success and wealth in the
late 1990s a teenage tunham wanted to be
an actor and was attending film school
but he was yet to book any work hunam
explained on The Graham Norton Show that
he found himself Christmas shopping on
Christmas Eve after having spent the
previous 4 hours in a pub drinking I was
in JD Sports trying on some Trainers for
my brother having a bit of a dance
around drunk a woman in the store was
watching his inebriated act so Hanam
playfully blew her a kiss the woman
turned out to be the production manager
of biker Grove a long running
family-friendly UK drama about the
goings on at an urban youth group hunam
was invited to audition and he landed a
part on the show as a character named
Jason it's all laid on in this game all
we have to do is look good and cash the
checks although it's been over a decade
since it first graced theaters
Forgetting Sarah Marshall is still
widely revered as one of the finest
romantic comedies of its era who could
forget the ludicrously humorous plight
of Jason seagull's Peter Breer who
regrettably vacations at the same Resort
as his ex-girlfriend Superstar actress
Sarah Marshall and her new bow eccentric
rocker aldus snow every actor in this
2008 classic feels perfectly picked for
their respective roles but as it turns
out the cast wasn't always set in stone
particularly with one key part Believe
It or Not Russell Brand wasn't the first
choice to play Alis snow speaking to
collider Charlie hunam revealed that
seagull who both wrote and starred in
the film had actually originally written
the part for him hunam and seagull were
close friends at the time having
recently worked together on the early
2000s comedy series Undeclared hunam
ultimately decided that the part wasn't
right for him but he admitted that he
really struggled turning his friend down
however when he saw a piece of Brand's
standup he felt assured about his
decision saying obviously that's the
dude who should have been playing that
role my relationship with Jason gave
birth to that character but there's no
way I could have done it justice the way
Russell bran did it's very
flexible before Jamie Dornan slipped
into the highly provocative role of
Christian Gray in 2015's 50 Shades of
Gray Universal was apparently all in on
Charlie hunam for the part in fact the
author of The wildly popular literary
series El James even made the
announcement over Twitter in
2013 however as most people know by now
the pairing just wasn't meant to be
hunam ultimately dropped out of the role
due to scheduling difficulties while
Doran wound up being a perfectly
suitable replacement some fans still
wonder what could have been had hunam
not turned down the role as it turns out
the Crimson Peak actor himself sometimes
does too in 2014 hunam got candid with
reporters about missing out on what
could have been the role of a lifetime
saying when you put the time into
something like that and a character
comes alive in your mind it's
heartbreaking not to be able to play him
it was definitely kind of heartbreaking
having to say goodbye to that character
and not bring it to life to the average
Joe locking lips with some of
Hollywood's most attractive women might
sound like a dream come true however in
an interview with L hunam revealed that
he truthfully has a very different
opinion on the matter admitting everyone
thinks it's great to be an actor and get
to kiss a bunch of beautiful actresses
in films but I actually hate it while he
admits that his longtime partner Morgana
McNelis is not the biggest fan of
watching her main man get steamy on
screen with another woman the Pacific
Rim star cites a different personal
phobia that explains his distaste for
spit swapping scenes I've got a little
bit of germaphobia oh you're a gerapo I
try to keep it clean okay okay while
this may seem like a bit of a
peculiarity there's actually a long list
of celebs who are huge germaphobes so
he's certainly not alone in that regard
knowing all of the intimate scenes
required for 50 Shades of Gray maybe
it's best that hunam passed on the role
of Christian Gray after all throughout
the history of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a number of actors and
actresses have seen their careers
explode due to their heroic onscreen
portrayals although it's now nearly
impossible to Envision anyone but Chris
Hemsworth in the mighty Marvel role of
Thor the studio originally had its eye
on hunam for the gig during a press
conference at 2017's Cinema con big
screen Achievement Award
Charlie hunam divulged that before they
found Hemsworth Marvel was interested in
bringing him on to play the god of
thunder in 2011's Thor he recalled I
auditioned and I met with the director
and the guys at Marvel several times and
it was sort of this awkward dance that
we were having he went on to add that
neither party totally bought into the
idea but he and the filmmakers played
around with a potential casting for a
while why did they ultimately change
their minds hunam bluntly added then
they found Chris Emsworth and that ended
[Music]
abruptly there are certainly more than a
few Hollywood Elites who prefer playing
some celebs are consistently single some
are constantly changing who they're
dating and some have even been engaged
multiple times Charlie Hunnam's public
dating profile is a little less
extravagant compared to most of his
peers although the rumor mill has thrown
Hunnam's name into more than a few
unverified relationships he's kept his
dating life pretty close to the chest
when the English star was only 18 years
old he came to America to audition for
Dawson's Creek although he didn't get
the part he met a fellow actor at the
audition named Katherine Town only 3
weeks later the two went to Las Vegas
and got hitched the couple stayed
together for 3 years before divorcing in
2002 a few years later hunam started
seeing American jewelry designer Morgana
McNelis and apparently the two were
simply made for each other they've been
together ever since I've been with my
girlfriend for 14 and 1/2 years if
you're working on a super intense TV
show for an extended period of time
there's bound to be some dramatic
tension build up behind the scenes for a
series like Sons of Anarchy which was
just as much a character piece as it was
a brutally violent drama it's totally
understandable that the show's actors
would Clash at times with the people in
charge speaking to Men's Journal hunam
admitted that sometimes things got a
little dicey on set between he and the
show's Creator Kurt Sutter saying I love
that guy but it was hard for us to work
together sometimes because we're both
crazy there has been security rushing
onto set and pulling us apart before
although that may sound a little
alarming there's nothing but love
between the two men today hunam referred
to Suter as his Hollywood dad in an
interview with Men's Health noting the
shared respect within the pair's
relationship apparently the feeling is
mutual when speaking on the the 100%
honest pretty much podcast Sutter also
had nothing but flattering things to say
about his Show's former lead you may
know him as Broody biker bad boy JX
teller from the ultraviolent FX hit
drama Sons of Anarchy or as the stoic
hero of Pacific Rim but Charlie hunam is
much more than your stereotypical Action
Hero I think this guy's dead but let's
check for a pulse
okay behind the scenes he's a apparently
a bit more reserved than the characters
he portrays in shoot them up
Blockbusters in an interview with GQ
hunam who turned 40 in 2020 discussed
how getting older has put his career in
a bit of a transitional phase and that
writing has become his primary focus
saying I've spent these last 6 to 8
months writing 5 hours a week I wrote a
screenplay and I wrote a television show
a six-part television show and right now
I'm in the middle of writing a
miniseries he's actually sold four
screenplays to Major Studio Studios
throughout his career and although none
of them have been made yet he's still
really enjoying the process of all the
screenplays Charlie hunam has written
the most high-profile and notable is his
script about the life of Vlad the
Impaler the 15th century Noble who
inspired the Dracula story according to
Entertainment Weekly hunam began writing
Vlad in 2006 and 3 years later with a
writer strike and the author Landing a
regular acting gig on Sons of Anarchy
development finally began despite that
production still hasn't begun on Vlad
more than a decade after it was first
announced although on screen he often
portrays tough guys and Scrappy badasses
Charlie hunam apparently has a major
soft spot for kitty cats in real life in
particular his pet cat George who he
rescued on his roof during a rainstorm I
thought it was a piece of wood he was
lying like this half submerged in a
puddle and I picked him up and my heart
broke when his longtime partner Organa
McNelis took to her Instagram to try and
start a GoFundMe page for a kitten in
need of surgery her main man came
through in a major way in a post
updating her followers on the kitten's
progress McNelis wrote Charlie just
found out about the GoFundMe for
Stitch's surgery and was very upset that
I did not ask him directly he insists on
covering the remaining cost of the vet
bills apparently she didn't ask him in
the first place because he had already
paid for another CAT surgery that month
Charlie hunam is a friend to not just
feed lines but dogs as well in 2019
Entertainment Weekly posted an adorable
video to their Instagram page showing
hunam cuddling up with puppies for
National Pet Day nowadays it seems like
TV reboots spin-offs and long running
continuations have become an industry
Norm Netflix's Fuller house breathed new
life into the legendary 9 sitcom Full
House in
2016 meanwhile Star Trek Bard returned
Sir Patrick Stewart to his long extinct
Star Trek role role and peacock's remake
of Save By the Bell brought a few
familiar faces including Mario Lopez and
Elizabeth Berkeley back to Bayside High
while some Stars may be all too happy to
slip back into the roles that jump
started their Hollywood careers Charlie
hunam isn't one of them while the
British actor is genuinely grateful for
the show that put him on the map he has
absolutely no intention of ever
returning to the world of Sons of
Anarchy as Jax Teller he's you know he's
not with us anymore and so I would never
bring him back from the dead for
something like that for Charlie hunam
it's all about looking forward in
life for decades he was touted as the
best of the bonds but there's more to
Shan Connor's life than his days as a
secret agent on October 31st 2020 the
actor died in his sleep in the Bahamas
following a long illness this is the
story of his life beyond Bond born to a
workingclass family in Edinburgh
Scotland in 1930 Thomas Shan connory had
a childhood that belil the Glamorous
Life for which he was event destined
including leaving school at the age of n
to begin working to help his family get
by I used to walk to work in the dark
and my mother went to work at the same
time and then I used to go straight from
there at 6:00 in the morning and go
straight to school like many young
people connory did not immediately
gravitate to what would become his very
successful career instead he joined the
Royal Navy at the age of 16 about a year
after World War II ended he spent not
quite 3 years in the Navy earning the
title of AEL Seaman assigned to the HMS
formidable however he was discharged at
the age of 19 because of dadal ulcers an
Affliction which ran in his family both
before and after his stint in the Navy
connory took on many odd jobs such as
delivering milk brick laying
lifeguarding and even coffin polishing
in a Spare Time connory took up
bodybuilding competing in the 1953 Mr
Universe competition though he
eventually drifted away from
bodybuilding he used his physique as an
artist model at the Edinburgh College of
artart connory was repeatedly praised as
one of the sexiest men alive so it
stands reason that he spent a good deal
of his youth engaged in activities that
centered on his body and his Beauty well
I mean what are you supposed to reply to
that Sean connory was nothing if not a
very dedicated hard worker it seems he
never rested on his Laurels even if it
did take him some jumping around from
job to job before he committed to acting
he spent about 8 years modeling and
taking on bit parts and chorus Parts in
stage plays TV and film before he got a
foothold and starring roles his first
major part on the Silver Screen was
opposite Lana Turner in the 1958 film
another time another place four years
later he would assume the role that went
on to make him world famous starring in
the original James Bond movie Dr No it
is startling in retrospect that a man
from such humble beginnings became
nearly synonymous with the sexy
sophisticated international Man of
Mystery it lends Credence to the idea
that anyone really can become anything
if they put in the efforts and if
they're very very lucky once connory
became Bond it was all uphill for his
career many actors are the progyny of
other actors and connory passed his
acting genes down to his son from first
marriage Jason connory though not as
famous as his father was Jason has
enjoyed a steady stable career since
appearing at the age of 20 in the Lords
of disciplin in 1983 aside from acting
he has also helmed film projects as
director starting with the film pandemic
in 2008 in a funny link to his dad Jason
played a film version of bond author Ian
Fleming in the TV drama spy maker The
Secret Life of Ian Fleming though
connory was known around the world as
Sir Shan connory for the last 20 years
of his life it was a bumpy road to his
eventual nighting in 20
it was widely rumored that he was twice
denied Knighthood by Donald der former
Scottish labor party politician because
of his political views connory is a
member of the Scottish national party a
central left party which favors Scottish
independence from the United Kingdom
needless to say Scottish independence is
a bit of a snub to the good old Queen of
England so it's fair to see that Britain
may not want to extend the honor of
Knighthood to a man so vocally opposed
to its monarchy incidentally darar
passed away on October 2000 just a few
months after connory received his
Knighthood despite Connor 's dedication
to the Scottish national party he seemed
to have been very proud of his
Knighthood he was credited as Sir Sean
connory in more recent roles though
Connor's rise from Rags to Riches makes
for an incredible story there are a few
shadier aspects of his life and career
one of those being his allegedly fraught
relationship with taxes connory was
accused of being a tax Exile living away
from Scotland to avoid paying income
taxes he released his tax information in
2003 to dispel these rumors though there
are claims that he would have paid more
if he had lived in the country at the
time he again came under Fire for
alleged property tax fraud regarding a
villa he and his wife owned in Marbella
Spain though connory was acquitted his
wife Micheline Rock Brun was
investigated initially the fraud has
been referred to as operation Goldfinger
call back to one of Connor's Bond films
I think you've made your point
Goldfinger thank you for the
demonstration though he reached the end
of his life while living in the Bahamas
Connor is most inextricably linked with
Scotland a place he maintained he would
only move back to if and when it gained
independence from Britain but there is
another land that has chosen to honor
the famous Scot Estonia more
specifically the Scottish club of Talon
Estonia funded a bronze bus to the actor
through private donations the Scottish
club begun as a society to sample
whiskey is comprised of estonians
enamored with Scottish culture as well
as a handful of Scottish expatriates
connory is not the first influential
Scott the club is honored with a statue
his bus joins out of Robert Burns the
18th century poet perhaps best known for
Penning ald Lang sign and often
recognized as Scotland's national poet
Talon might seem like a strange location
for a society honoring Scottish Legends
but it's clear that the members who
raised about $14,000 to have the statue
made are dedicated to their cause just
about every celebrity has a pet cause or
area of activism that they regularly
support for connory his own upbringing
is prompted an interest in education he
helped co-found the Scottish
International Education trust in 1971
with his friend sir Jackie Stewart to
financially support promising Scots
achieve a better education in fact
connory donated his entire salary from
from his work on the Bond film diamonds
are forever to the trust a sum which his
website claims was well over $1 million
his philanthropy doesn't stop there but
his site declines to list the Apparently
Myriad Charities and worthy causes the
Stars supported instead it prompts
visitors to consider helping others as
he has and lists his main areas of
Interest education culture and Scotland
it seems he doesn't take his own big
break for granted acknowledging that the
helpy received as a young man made an
immeasurable difference Sean connory is
a sex symbol the kind of man many
wouldn't be surprised to learn has a
long list of Ex-Wives and jilted lovers
in fact he only has one ex-wife Deon
salento and has been married to his
second wife michelene Rock Brun since
1975 Rock Brun is an accomplished
painter who favors portraiture in bright
Hughes her Gallery available to view on
her husband's website her long marriage
to Connor though it seemed amicable
enough even despite her taking the fall
in their tax fraud Scandal hasn't always
been the perfect pairing however the man
best known for portraying the
chauvinistic bond has had some misogyny
problems of his own including a very
public romantic affair with pop star
Lindsay to Paul a woman 18 years as
Junior Still Rock Brun remained with
connory until the end of his life
perhaps the most distinctive thing about
connory for many filmgoers is his voice
that deep rolling Scottish brogue
despite this he hasn't done a wealth of
Voice work limiting such roles to a few
special projects one of those projects
was the 2005 video game From Russia with
Love for which he reprised his role as
James Bond long before that he played
Draco the computer generated dragon in
dragonart The Last Dragon on Earth Draco
teams up with an nursed wild Dragon
Hunter a monk and a young woman on a
quest to save England from a tyrannical
King it's a fun sentimental fantasy
adventure and Connor's Draco holds up
surprisingly well the less said about
the franchise that followed the better
as recently as 2012 connory came out of
retirement to play the title role in the
film sir Billy an animated film about a
Scottish veteranarian that connory
produced his tone and delivery also make
him a natural choice for a narrator a
role he's filled only once for a TV
documentary other than that the best way
to hear the man is to watch him in the
flesh and one of the many many films he
left behind is his
legacy actor comedian musician
Spider-Man Donald Glover has many hats
but how much do you really know about
this entertainment icon keep watching
for the untold and surprising truth
about Donald
Glover while attending NYU Donald Glover
became a part of Derek comedy a sketch
comedy group that performed regularly
from 2006 to 2010 it was a formative
time for internet culture and the group
took full advantage of the new medium
quickly achieving widespread notoriety
with their videos it wasn't long before
they racked up a healthy fan base on
YouTube with comedic skits gaining
National media attention before parting
ways completely Glover joined forces
with his sketch comedy crew and released
a detective comedy feature called
mystery team Derek comedy member DC
Pearson told past magazine that the film
was inspired by the group's Collective
appreciation of encyclop cedia Brown in
2010 paja called the film The Smart kind
of dumb and with appearances by the
likes of Aubrey Plaza and Bobby moan the
comedy's cult status is only grown over
time Donald Glover was still living as
an RA in his NYU dorm when SNL Alum Tina
Fay came calling his work with Derek
comedy had popped up on her radar and
she actively pursued him to write for
her new NBC comedy 30 Rock as Fay writes
in her Memoir bossy pants because he
came from a large family Georgia he was
very helpful in writing for the
character Kenneth the page why did he
get this amazing opportunity Fay
admitted to the New Yorker that race was
a big factor she admired Glover's Talent
sure but it was NBC's diversity
initiative that made him affordable or
another Words Free as Glover told
Entertainment Weekly it just helped you
learn the rules of everything Tina Fay
taught me how to write but also about
the politics of television and a tribute
to Glover for Time magazine's 100 most
influential issue in 2018 Fay wrote he
embodies his generation's belief that
people can be whatever they want and
change what it is they want at any time
when you're tired of starring in a
network comedy take a break to pursue
your rap career for a Grammy nomination
when you've learned all you can from
acting and other people's movies sit
down and create your own piece of art
Donald Glover was raised a Jehovah's
Witness a religious lifestyle that found
him sheltered from much of what pop
culture had to offer I was always taught
like the world was kind of a bad place
so like whenever things came in I'd be
like yo this is really dope looking at
him now it's kind of hard to imagine the
lack of music movies and television in
the young Glover's life but that's not
for lack of trying Glover would listen
to Bootleg audio of Simpsons episodes in
bed at night once saw The Phantom Menace
at the movies and even managed to get
away with catching the odd Muppet movie
this unique upbringing shaped Glover
into the multi-talented artist he is
today and funny enough his role of Troy
Barnes in community was the first openly
Jehovah's Witness character on TV that
one's probably no
coincidence 2008 was an interesting time
for television Not only was the country
immersed in a presidential election
season members of the writer Guild were
on strike causing scripted episodic TV
to come to a halt as the strike came to
an end rumors suggested that Saturday
Night Live was looking for a new face to
step in as then Senator Barack Obama the
show auditioned a number of performers
for the role including Jordan Peele
Jordan Carlos and Donald Glover it took
a few more years for Peele to bring his
Obama impersonation to TV with comedy
Central's Key and Peele would Glover's
Barack impersonation have been worthy of
the late night Spotlight it's possible
in the end though Lauren Michaels gave
Saturday Night Live cast member Fred
Armon the role just one year later
Glover made his jump from writer to TV
actor with his debut as lovable athlete
Troy Barnes on Dan harman's cult favorit
sitcom Community good news guys I spent
all my money why you can't bring that in
here yes I can it's all terrain dummy
Glover's breakthrough role was on the
NBC sitcom Community but his time as
high school football star turned grade a
weirdo Troy Barnes was often fraught
behind the scenes not the least of which
was due to the antics of co-star Chevy
Chase the xsn L cast member has long had
a reputation for being difficult to work
with and fulfilled Expectations by
seemingly alienating every member of the
community cast and crew when it came to
Glover many of Chase's remarks and
off-color jokes had a racial Edge to
them and perhaps some professional
jealousy Community Creator and
showrunner Dan Harmon told the New
Yorker in 2018 Chevy was the first to
realize how immensely gifted Donald was
and the way he expressed that jealousy
was to throw Donald off Glover and Chase
would both leave the show after a
troubled fourth season although Harmon
convinced Glover to return for a handful
of season 5 episodes there appears to be
no one reason why Lover Left Community
rather it was a combination of factors
including artistic restlessness the
behindth scene turmoil of that previous
season and the development of his FX
series
Atlanta in 2010 Twitter was lit up by a
campaign to get Donald Glover cast a
Spider-Man Glover himself started the
campaign in a tongue-and-cheek way and
even referenced it by appearing in
Spider-Man pajamas on an episode of
community but the hashtag Donald for
Spider-Man took on a life of its own
comic book writer Brian Michael Bendis
eventually took notice and in 2011 he
introduced a new Spider-Man to Marvel
Comics ultimates series Miles Morales a
black and Latino teenager at least
partially modeled after Glover referring
to that episode of community Bendis told
USA Today he looked fantastic I saw him
in the costume and thought I would like
to read that book Glu missed out the
2012 Sony reboot The Amazing Spider-Man
which used the Peter Parker version of
the character but he did voice Morales
in a two-part episode of the Animated
Series Ultimate Spider-Man in 2017 he
made his Marvel Cinematic Universe debut
in Spider-Man homecoming playing
smalltime crook Aaron Davis known in the
comics as the prowler who also happens
to be miles morales's Uncle the in jokes
and references get even more twisted
around in 2018s Spider-Man into the
spiderverse the reality hopping animated
film centers on Miles Morales and
includes a cameo of sorts by Glover as
Aaron Davis can be seen watching the
episode of community that featured
Glover dressed as
Spider-Man by 2012 Donald Glover had
collected an impressive number of
accomplishments especially for someone
who'd had their big TV break just a few
years prior with all the work he' put
out into the World by that point he had
shown a proclivity for inducing laughs
and what's the simplest way of doing
this why standup comedy of course in
2010 Glover tested the waters with the
half-hour special Comedy Central
presents Donald Glover it was a time of
transition in between his work on 30
Rock and community and the awkwardly
energetic aesthetic he cultivated with
Derek comedy was present throughout the
performance just something about men the
second they realize they crazy it's like
time to kill everything I love time to
kill it all it's all coming with me he
followed up this Dent with an hour-long
special 2 years later titled Donald
Glover weirdo by this point though he
had begun releasing music under the
Childish Gambino moniker while joke
telling could have remained fruitful
hip-hop was calling and it proved to be
an even more worthwhile
Venture When Donald Glover started
making mixtapes he released them under
the rap name Childish Gambino it's a
colorful moniker to be sure but what
does it mean Glover explained on Late
Night with Jimmy Fallon that he acquired
the name from a wuang clan name
generator he said and then we're all
putting them in and they're all funny
and stuff and then mine came up and I
was like you guys it's not funny anymore
this is this is something big like I
just really liked it but what does it
actually mean in a 2011 fuse interview
Glover recalled a conversation he had
with Wu Tang's Rizza who apparently had
some valuable Insight he's like yo it's
like the computer Had a Brain it's like
you're childish but you could also
murder someone Glover was quick to point
out that he wouldn't ever kill anybody
instead summing it all up by saying for
me it's kind of just like silliness and
kind of
seriousness his name May signify a blend
of silliness and seriousness but
Childish Gambino explored a deeper level
of artistry with 2016's awaken my love
as Rolling Stone argued in their review
of the Grammy winning album Gambino
delves into the kind of grungy stank
love that Outcast once indulged in on
their Magnum opuses as Gambino's music
has continued to mature Donald Glover's
live performances have evolved as well
it all culminated in feros a live
immersive Music Festival that Glover
devised with Microsoft the 4-day event
that transpired in Joshua Tree
California was crafted for a small group
of people and and feature performances
by a number of other musicians including
Glover's longtime collaborator lvic
Goron as Glover told Vanity Fair feros
is meant to be a communal space a place
that evolves and reacts to the culture
we're selling real intimacy we protect
the experience and it becomes something
you genuinely share with the people
around you and you take away something
special we're looking at expanding the
world in 2018 there will be more artists
involved sure enough another pharoh
event took place in New New Zealand in
November 2018 what the future holds for
Glovers mini Festival however remains to
be seen up until 2014 Donald Glover was
pretty active on social media he
regularly shared humorous thoughts and
quips on Twitter and even stirred up
rumors about his mental wellbeing after
a series of posts on Instagram Glover
explained his dark Instagram admissions
by saying I just wanted to write down my
feelings I definitely was just
expressing myself not long after Glover
drastically limited his social media use
message he later told the New Yorker I
felt like social media was making me
less human and I already didn't feel
that human expanding on his issue with
the internet citing the lack of personal
connectivity Glover admitted to Esquire
that he largely uses social media
anonymously he said I try and find
subcultures I try and find communities I
talk to people as a regular person it's
the only place you can be
anonymous curious why Donald Glover has
a mention in the end credits of black
panther it turns out that he and and his
brother Steven stepped in to help punch
up some jokes in director Ryan cougler
script glver told Entertainment Tonight
Ryan was gracious enough to be like will
you take a look at this script which was
really cool Marvel locks things down so
we had not as much time as I would have
wanted they had already done a great job
so it was really cool to just get our
fingerprints on there a bit Glover has
been known to add some comedy Consulting
when time allows it take Chance the
Rapper for example not only have they
worked on music together but Glover gave
the rapper some sketch writing
assistance when he hosted SNL in
November of 2017 so I brought a few
sketches by one of them made it I
actually got to give credit to my good
friend Donald Glover who helped me uh
with the
idea Glover's explanation of the vibe of
Atlanta to the television critics
Association in 2016 was as succinct as
it was difficult to picture I just
wanted to make Twin Peaks with rappers
Twin Peaks The Surreal David Lynch
television series whose Central murder
mystery made it an unlikely hit in its
first season see seemed like an odd
comparison at the time in fact everyone
expected a comedy more along the lines
of what Glover was doing on community
what Glover and his collaborators
delivered instead is a comedy and name
only or one that often substitutes
unease and Dread for belly laughs Glover
Star is his earn an aimless man who has
fallen into managing the career of his
cousin Alfred a mid-level Atlanta rapper
known as paper boy the show is
frequently hilarious but what Glover
shares with David Lynch is a sense of
The Uncanny and the Sinister lurking in
everyday life for Lynch that everyday
life is the white picked vences of blue
velvet or the quirky logging Town of
Twin Peaks for Glover it's the already
surreal world of black life in America
and like fellow comedian turned horror
Maestro Jordan Peele Glover understands
how little it takes to tweak the daily
struggles of black Americans into
something bizarre and
terrifying Atlanta is nominally a comedy
and there's a fair share of humor
featured throughout the series but the
subject matter goes much deeper
stylistically there's nothing else like
it on television chalk that up to the
partnership between Donald Glover and
director hero marai who developed their
working relationship during multiple
Childish Gambino music video shoots
together they have collaborated to make
Atlanta the emmy-winning force it is
today not many people know though that
the show's aesthetic comes from a short
film that Mari and Glover made in 2013
as Mari told Esquire much of the show's
DNA came from a 2013 movie called
clapping for the wrong reasons this is a
short that he and Glover made about a
rap star moving from room to room in his
Mansion drifting among the friends and
possessions he' collected Film School
reject commented on the style of the
film writing compared to the high
concepts of some of Mariah's music
videos it feels downbeat and almost like
an LA version of Mumble core micro
budget movies about creatives aimlessly
searching for themselves you hate
women what as if all of Donald Glover's
accomplishments weren't enough he also
made emy's history when he received two
accolades for his work on Atlanta
outstanding directing for a comedy
series as well as outstanding lead actor
in a comedy series Glover became the
first black director to win in the
comedy category understandably it was
all a bit overwhelming I I blacked out I
don't know yeah like I was not ready for
that he explained further saying he was
in a weird phase when he directed ban
the episode for which he won his Emmy I
was doing a lot okay I was like a new
father
writing other episodes and dirting and
like cing together he went on to say I'm
really astonished I was really
shocked one of the most bizarre and
disturbing episodes of Atlanta was
season 2's Teddy Perkins in this episode
Ern and Alfred's Stoner philosopher
friend Darius shows up to a large house
outside the city to pick up a free piano
there he encounters Teddy Perkins a
reclusive light-skinned facelifted
former songwriter who is also played by
L Teddy insists on giving Darius a tour
of the house which doubles as a museum
dedicated to himself and his brother who
lives in the Attic suffice to say things
get very creepy very quickly this is the
furthest Atlanta has tipped into
outright horror at least in its first
three seasons it was made all the more
unsettling when glver brought his
terrifying creation into the real world
apparently dressing as Teddy Perkins at
the 2018 Emmy Awards when he was
nominated for best actor in a comedy
series the word apparently is important
here because later in the evening Glover
and Teddy Perkins Were Somehow
photographed together so who was sitting
in Glover's seat internet sleuths
scoured the possibilities for months an
e newss report at the time quoted a
source claiming that the person under
the makeup was former SNL cast member
Jay Pharaoh which Pharaoh all but
confirmed in a 2021 video interview with
K Nast Traveler had to be somebody under
there right had to be somebody 3 hours
of make W up in 2018 Childish Gambino
released this is America the song and
it's accompanying hero Mari directed
video was an immediate viral hit it
launched a thousand think pieces
scouring its every lyric and image for
meaning marai presents the bulk of the
video as a single take following Glover
through an empty Warehouse alternating
between moments of joy to moments of
shocking violence likewise the music
crashes buoyant Caribbean inspired
rhythms up against The Haunting drone of
its chor us Glover performed the song
when he hosted Saturday Night Live that
year and a version of it also appeared
in Glover's 2019 short film guava Island
it also became the first rap song to
ever win song of the year at the Grammys
Glover's work elicited a number of
negative reactions as well with some
taking issue with what they saw as his
exploiting black trauma and violence
under the guise of making art he's also
been accused of plagiarism on more than
one occasion in 2018 fans noted the
similarities between this is America and
rapper Jace Harley's 2016 song American
Pharaoh Harley declined to take legal
action apparently grateful just to be
part of the conversation in 2021 however
the rapper kid West filed a suit against
Glover on behalf of his own 2016 song
made in America Glover maintains that
this is America predates both Harley and
kid West's tracks season 3 of Atlanta
premiered in March 2022 after a 4-year
Hiatus during that time one of GL
Lover's most high-profile gigs was the
2019 liveaction remake of Disney's The
Lion King director John favro and an
army of visual effects artists crafted a
new version of the classic 1994 animated
film and photorealistic CGI but
crucially retained the original film's
award-winning songs this meant that
Glover playing Simba had to sing the
well-known duet Can You Feel the Love
Tonight with Nala played in the remake
by Beyonce noes Carter Glover was in
London filming solo a star Wars story at
the time so he recorded his vocals
separately which as he joked on Jimmy
Kimmel Live was probably a good thing
for him I did not want to be looking
into Beyonce's eyes while doing this
despite being an acclaimed recording
artist in his own right having to match
pipes with Beyonce in the same room
would be a pretty nerve-wracking thing
in the segment Kimmel suggests that it
was probably less intimidating to record
separately Glover agrees I imagine it's
less intimidating playing basketball
with Michael Jordan yeah if you're at
home just
throwing he was written into the big
Labowski without his knowledge and he
officially in the mustache Hall of Fame
keep watching for so much more about the
Untold Truth of Sam Elliott born in 1944
in Sacramento California Sam Elliott
began acting in the late 60s he did what
a lot of actors before him had done he
started out in small roles in television
westerns eventually earning slightly
more substantial Parts in the hit shows
Lancer and Mission Impossible his first
role in a major film came in 1969's
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid which
featured the Superstar leads Paul Newman
and Robert Redford in the title roles a
comedic Western based on the lives of
two notorious bank robbing Outlaws the
film seems like a perfect fit for
Elliott who spent much of his career
working within the genre fortunately for
him he had a blink and you'll miss it
Parts as a card player he didn't even
have any lines while the role didn't
have much of an impact on his career the
movie did have a rather coincidental
place in his life starring beside Newman
and Redford was Katherine Ross and
though she and Elliot shared no scenes
and didn't cross pass during filming
nearly 10 years later they did meet
again and started dating his co-leads in
the Legacy it wasn't long before the
couple were married today they're still
together and they have a daughter over
the course of the 1970s and 1980s Sam
Elliott never quite hit it big but he
did enjoy increasing recognition as a
character actor appearing in television
shows TV movies and big screen
Productions his first major starring
role in a feature film came in 1976 as
lifeguard which tells the tale of a
lifeguard working in Southern California
who's forced into self-reflection after
attending a high school reunion and
realizing that his classmates have
accomplished greater things with their
lives while the movie performed decently
in the box office Elliot publicly
complained about the film's marketing
during the promotional tour which caused
the studio heads at paramont to become
displeased as a result he never worked
with the company again that wasn't the
only trouble he experienced during this
period during an interview in 1980
Elliot revealed that he had been
propositioned repeatedly during
auditions saying you cannot believe the
casting couch stories I could tell you
you man the cliches are all true I've
had propositions from men and women and
I've turned them all down it's probably
hurt me but I'm the one who has to live
with that guilt my conscience is clear
even though my career is still not
setting the world on fire perhaps
unsurprisingly he later became a vocal
supporter of the Me 2 movement however
these decades weren't all hard times as
he scored a number of high-profile roles
in 1985 he stared in a supporting role
alongside share and mask then in 1989 he
starred next to Patrick sey in the cult
classic Roadhouse
by the time the 1990s rolled around Sam
Elliott had spent more than 20 years in
Hollywood but he still didn't have much
in the way of name recognition for the
most part he seemed destined to forever
be a somewhat acknowledged face without
a name with the arrival of his third
decade in the business however that was
about to change after playing a
substantial part in the critically
acclaimed Civil War epic Gettysburg
Elliot starred alongside Kurt Russell in
the now classic Western Tombstone which
was hailed by audiences and critics
alike in the role of Virgil herb from
the famous real life old west family of
lawmen headed by the renowned Wyer
Elliott was particularly captivating
this helped to propel him into prominent
Parts in future films sadly enough
Elliott's father who never wanted him to
become an actor didn't get a chance to
see his success begin the two sparred
over the career choice and were never
able to settled their differences as his
father died of a heart attack when
Elliot was just 18 many years later
while speaking in an interview with the
star Elliot explained he died thinking
man this kid is going to go down the
wrong path and I think on some levels
that was either hard on me or made me
more more focused in my resolve to have
a career you know what I mean these days
the big Labowski is almost universally
considered one of the Cohen Brothers
greatest films and one of its many
iconic characters is Elliot's The
Stranger a surreal narrator who delivers
some of the movie's most quotable
lines Darkness washed over the
dude darker than a Black Steer tcus on a
moonless prairie night according to an
interview in the New York Times Elliott
was initially disappointed at being cast
as yet another Cowboy now was until he
read the script speaking to NPR Elliot
explained that as he looked through the
screenplay he spotted a surprise as he
explained it over the dialogue there's
this tumbling tumble weed blowing and
talk about this southwest accent and
sounding not unlike Sam Elliott I had my
name in The Script later as they were
filming his final scene Elliot became
exasperated by going through take after
take the Cohen Brothers finally admitted
that they had already gotten what they
wanted but they enjoyed watching and
listening to him so much that they had
him do it again and again well had a bad
desert
reps are all up part of what helped
Propel Sam Elliot to success was his
distinctive voice and over the years
he's lent into to a wide variety of
high-profile commercials perhaps the
most notable products you might have
heard is familiar voice Hawking or K's
beer and Dodge Ram heavyduty trucks
since 2008 Elliott has also voiced Smoky
bear the US Forest Service mascot
created to help with Wildfire prevention
efforts you probably have heard his
catchphrase only you can prevent
wildfires another fun fact Elliot not
only delivers Smokey's famous
catchphrase but he actually shares his
birth date with a fictional spokes bear
August 9th
1944 while Sam Elliot star has been
rising steadily for some 20 years or so
in the 2010s he really took off by the
middle of the decade he had recurring
roles in the Netflix series The Ranch
and Grace and Frankie he also lent his
voice to the 2015 animated film the good
dinosaur then in 2017 Elliot starred in
the hero a film about an aging Western
Star whose best days are behind him Not
only was it the perfect role for him but
according to the film's writer and
director Brett Haley it was literally
written for Elliott as Haley explained
to the LA Times to me it was a love
letter not only to Sam but to a dying
breed of actor in film in Hollywood
shortly after that Elliot starred in the
Flatout bizarre B film the man who
killed Hitler and then the Bigfoot which
fared well with critics thanks largely
to Elliot's
performance in 2018 Sam Elliot hit
another major High Point in his career
so far with his performance in A Star is
Born directed by Bradley Cooper and
starring Cooper Elliots and Lady Gaga
the movie is about the relationship
between an up-and-coming singer and her
alcoholic Mentor A Star is Born was a
massive success by every measure earning
$436 million on a $36 million budget it
garnered almost Universal praise from
the critics and scored eight Oscar
nominations including best picture one
win for best original song and one
nomination for best supporting actor for
Sam Elliott shingly this was his first
Academy Award nomination indicating that
even at 75 years old his career still
had exciting places to go Elliott's
performance in the film also earned him
a nomination for outstanding performance
by a male actor in a supporting role at
the Screen Actor Guild Awards and a win
for best supporting actor at the
national board of review Awards not bad
for an old cowboy along with his smooth
deep voice and tough demeanor Sam Elliot
is best recognized by his iconic
mustache and we're not the only ones who
think so in 2015 Elliot was inducted
into the mustache Hall of Fame alongside
the likes of real life Legends such as
Teddy Rose Roosevelt Hulk Hogan and
Billy D Williams as well as fictional
characters such as Ned Flanders and
yosity Sam talk about a distinguished
class of facial hair while we all know
and love his Superior upper lip sweater
Elliot himself doesn't quite understand
all the fuss Sam Elliott might not get
all the attention but we totally do
that's some ferocious facial fuzz he's
got there of course these days Sam
Elliot is among the most recognizable
faces in the industry as he continues to
shine on screens big and small his
latest breakout hit is 1883 on Paramount
plus a prequel to the series
Yellowstone Keo Reeves hit Hollywood
like a cool breeze in the80s that's what
his name means in Hawaiian and ever
since he's been one of Cinema's most
intriguing and versatile actors but is
his poetry any good was Alice Cooper
really his babysitter here's the Untold
Truth of Kiana Reeves when Reeves went
to The Late Show in December 2021 to
promote his return as Neo in The Matrix
resurrections Steven coar took upon
himself to divert the conversation a bit
and ask him about sad Kean an immensely
popular meme based on a 2010 picture of
re sullenly eating a sandwich on a bench
Reeves explained his State of Mind at
the time of the iconic meal I was
thinking I had some stuff going on sure
I was hungry like any of us ree was just
trying to fill his stomach and Ponder
the complexities of Life while doing so
but he inadvertently provided the
internet with one of the most viral
memes of all time back in 2011 when the
meme was still pretty fresh he told BBC
how he really feels about it do I wish
that I didn't get my picture taken and
while I was eating a sandwich on the
streets New York yeah living is
something that keano Reeves has been
doing for a long time the actor was born
in 1964 but some people on the internet
have come to believe that Reeves is a
whole lot older than 57 in 2010 a Reddit
poster noted that there is a striking
resemblance between Reeves and portraits
of Paul mune a french actor who died in
the early 20th century but whose body
was never found not long after the post
began drawing attention someone made a
small addition to man's Wikipedia page
writing he currently acts under the
pseudonym of keano Reeves the source of
his Eternal youth is not known the
addition went unchanged for several
weeks and Reeves's immortality
conspiracy was born it didn't take long
for the official keor Reeves's Immortal
website to enter the scene the S side
features pictures of Reeves throughout
the years and it does appear to age at
about the same rate as Paul Rd in
addition to mune Reeves is also
confirmed to have been King Charlemagne
who lived from 748 to 814 and crowned
his son as king shortly before dying and
undergoing a rushed winter burial It's a
Small World After All Kiana Reeves might
have played in dog star through the 9s
but his connection to rock and roll goes
back way further than that in an
interview with Jimmy Fallon Reeves
confirmed that Alice Cooper used to
babysit him as a kid Reeves explained
that he grew up in Toronto just down the
street from a recording studio called
Nimbus 9 Reeves's mother was a costume
designer who often worked with musicians
and she happened to have a connection
with Alice Cooper Reeves confessed that
he doesn't actually remember spending
any time with the rock legend he said
that's so red I mean I don't know how
that could actually possibly happen so
but it did supposedly yeah the only part
of the experience that Reeves can recall
is a prank that Cooper pulled he
recounted I remember that he uh that
there was fake poo in the fridge of
course actors and rock stars cross pass
all the time but it's not often that
their encounters lead to a story this
delightful everyone has to start
somewhere and Kiana Reeves got a start
in the movie business partially against
his will when he was still just a
teenager Reeves's stepfather Paul Aaron
was working on his second feature film
The Summer that Reeves turned 15 Reeves
told the guardian it was my summer
Holiday from school and for a parent
it's like what do you do with this kid
over the summer I know we'll make him a
production assistant on a movie a force
of one starring Chuck Norris wasn't the
most auspicious start to a film career
but the job got Reeves invested in the
magic of making movies Reeves said I was
watching the grips I was watching actors
I was seeing how a film set really works
he spent weeks learning the ins and outs
of a film set but mostly he fetched
buckets of ice to keep the drinks and
snacks cool still he learned his most
important lesson about filmm on that set
he said a movie is all hands on deck I
love all hands on deck that love has
never left Reeves and neither has his
work ethic during the production of John
Wick 4 Reeves blew up online yet again
when someone caught footage of him
lugging heavy equipment around like
another crew member 42 years later
Reeves is just as hardworking as ever in
one of Kiana reeves' earliest roles he
plays a hardworking cyclist who Powers
through a long race and gets rewarded
with a cool glass bottle of Coca-Cola
hey I'm proud of you really proud a Coke
Reeves reminisced about the role on The
Late Late Show with James cordon and the
memories brought a wide smile to his
face the 3-day commercial shoot was one
of Reeves's first tastes of being a
working actor and all these years later
he can still enthusiastically recall the
excitement and camaraderie that he felt
on the set with Reeves's reputation for
being one of the most hardworking actors
in Hollywood it will probably surprise
no one that he shaved his legs for the
role there aren't many actors even at
the beginning of their careers who would
go that far for a minute long coat
commercial because of his starring roles
in major Hollywood Blockbusters people
often think of Kiana Reeves as an
American movie star but that couldn't be
further from the truth if anything
Reeves was more of an international Man
of Mystery Reeves was born in Lebanon
after his parents english-born Patricia
and Chinese Hai and Samuel met on a
beach in Beirut shortly after Reeves's
birth the family moved to Australia and
not long after that his parents
separated ultimately Patricia relocated
the family to New York for a brief stint
before settling in Toronto reev has been
a Canadian citizen for most of his life
though his frequent trips to Los Angeles
and other parts of the world obscure
that fact for most of his fans when he
was asked in an interview why he keeps
his canadi Ian citizenship despite
spending so much of his time in the
United States he said I sometimes wonder
I've even regretted not having American
citizenship especially at election times
though Reeves clarified that he isn't an
activist he does have a strong belief
that elections are important he said
ideally I would take out dual
nationality dual citizenship might be
Reeves's preference but with over 100
acting roles in under 40 years he's
hardly had the time to enjoy his
Canadian citizenship much less seek out
another countries when a famous actor
pivots into writing a book or a series
of poems the results are usually mixed
at best K Reeves used The Stereotype to
his Advantage with his first poetry book
ODed to happiness which was published in
2011 each page contains a single line
from Reeves paired with an illustration
from his girlfriend artist Alexander
grant grant told to BBC that ODed to
happiness began its life as a joke she
said our friend sat at keo's house one
night listening to wonderfully sad
self-pitying songs and keano in the
spirits of poking fun at them began to
write a poem the book begins with the
line I draw a hot sorrow bath in my
despair rooms it then continues on in
that self-serious vein for the duration
Reeves is the first to acknowledge that
the overwrought style of the poem isn't
meant to be taken seriously Reeves told
BBC it's only personal in the sense of
looking out and regarding my sense of
humor I don't usually take baths in my
despair room with a misery candle
burning the collaboration was so
successful that it led to a second book
in 2016 Shadows once again pairs poetry
with art but this time the coupling
Isn't So humorous Reeves told the
guardian that the book was an attempt to
quote contextualize the grief that he's
faced in his life he hoped that by
writing about the grief he could quote
even be inspired by it even find a
certain pleasure in it as it turns out
poetry just wasn't enough to satisfy
Reeves's seemingly bottomless artistic
Drive in the fall of 2017 he sat down
with boom Studios to talk about a
character in story idea that had been
lingering in his mind for ages the
meeting was the most keano esque pitch
imaginable he acted out various scenes
from the story which follows an immortal
hyperviolet man constantly engaged in
combat and showed off his Decades of
fighting knowledge reev said it went
comic book I went yeah why not and with
that Berserker was born Reeves paired up
with veteran comic writer Matt kin the
Mind behind mind management to bring his
story to fruition the comic features an
80,000 year-old man who in keo's words
could punch people's chests and their
backs and rip people's arms off to life
the story was planned as a 12issue
miniseries and boom launched a
Kickstarter campaign to gauge interest
in the story The Studio ended up with
$1.5 million in pre-orders the wildly
successful comic is already being
considered for a film adaptation and
Reeves has stated that he would love to
play the role the project still needs to
find its perfect director but it likely
won't be long before Berserker hits the
big screen though it wasn't his first
time fighting his way through scenes and
set pieces Kiana Reeves became known as
an action movie star after the Matrix I
know Kung
Fu show me the film came out more than
20 years ago but as he's gotten older
Reeves has continually up the ante the
John Wick films directed by Reeves's
Matrix stunt double Chad steli are
filled with with the type of visceral
action that usually relies on camera
tricks and highly trained martial
artists however Reeves famously prefers
to handle the material himself he told
Sunday today I do all of the action I'm
90% of what's happening there he says
that doing action scenes in his 50s is
more about recovery than when he was
younger but if anything he's gotten
better with time Reeves doesn't
constrain his action prowess to a single
franchise either he shot some pretty
incredible stunts for his return to the
Matrix and the Matrix resurrections
Reeves told Steven coar on The Late Show
that he and keran Moss jumped off a 46
story building 19 to 20 times to nail
down the perfect shot when asked why he
didn't use CGI for the jump reev said
because it's lowski and it's the Matrix
and you need natural light and you want
to do it real that's a dedication of
someone who shaved their legs for a
commercial growing stronger with each
new opportunity after all the time that
Kiana Reeves has spent in front of the
camera it seems only appropriate that
he's gotten an opportunity to sit in the
director's chair 2013's man of taii
stars tiger hu chin as a young martial
artist who gets in too deep in an
underground fighting room Reeves not
only directed the film but also
stretched his acting range by starring
as the film's main antagonist the film
wasn't nearly as groundbreaking as
previous Reeves outings but the critical
consensus on Rotten Tomatoes calls it an
agreeably old-fashioned picture for
martial arts fans and a solid debut for
first-time director keano Reeves Reeves
hasn't directed a second film but that
doesn't mean he won't Berserker writer
Matt kin has thrown Reeves's name into
the hat for directing the comic's film
adaptation telling the Washington Post
there's no one better to pull it off
than him Gio Reeves has acted in more
movies than most people even aspire to
but don't let that trick you into
thinking that he's going to disappear
from the big screen anytime soon Reeves
told the guardian around the time I hit
40 there was this idea of creating more
for my artistic loins he said that he
often thinks about life like it's a reel
of tape when you're young you have a big
old reel of that tape left right and so
it appears to revolve slowly then time
passes and there's less and less tape
left on the reel it spins faster it
spins faster these days Reeves is trying
to move just as fast as his spinning
tape he's revisiting old franch ches
like the Matrix and Bill and Ted while
continuing to push forward on more
recent hits notably there are currently
two John Wick sequels in production at
the same time he's releasing poetry
showing up in video games and spending
time with the people closest to him he
said work doesn't slow time down if
anything it speeds everything up luckily
for us Reeves still has plenty of tape
left on his
[Music]
re